bye hidden away in the 3.5 trillion
dollar spending bill i believe it's page
168 the democrats have included
enforcement abilities for the vaccine
mandate with fines between 70 000 per
infraction upwards of 700 000
per infraction basically what they're
saying is
if you oppose us
we will nuke your company because look a
company might have 100 employees but
let's say you know let's say they're
bringing in with a hundred employees
seven eight mil per year and their and
their profits are only 15 percent of
that or or something like around there
they're basically saying if you don't do
as you're told we are going to
absolutely destroy your life the
suffering is the point now we're hearing
that border patrol agents are are being
given the the choice either you get
vaccinated or you lose your job you know
why that's really funny because they
don't have the same standard for the
illegal immigrants the border patrol
agents are trying to stop
so everything is just backwards broken
upside down but but despite all that
there are a lot of people that are
really optimistic on the right and those
who are opposite to the establishment
more populist individuals
because the abysmal ratings approval
rating for for joe biden signals in 2022
republicans are going to sweep in the
only problem with that is like who
expects republicans to do anything so uh
we'll talk about that but we're hanging
out with the illinois boys that's right
jack murphy i actually decided to come
back and and my friends my friends i
just want to just just so everybody
knows against my wish we are giving jack
a 40-year scotch to make sure we have a
great show i refuse i refuse i will have
none of this amazing delicious world
famous incredible best scotch i've ever
had i'll have no more he didn't have a
sip of it before the show yeah
it was pretty good it was pretty good
but i made it back you know tim i got a
lot of messages they said to me uh
it was been a good run on tim cass there
jack
that's what people said after the last
show but did people really think i was
like jack's never allowed because he was
arguing with me that's what he said to
me tim was in my dms he's like dude you
guys were both talking so much crap
about each other in my dm's pretty
brutal yeah you paced them together
and then i was like i was like sheamus
tell jack you can come back on the show
only if he promises to drink more scotch
right exactly and here it is a bottle of
scotch shame is like i'm not the middle
man just talk to him i was on the line
with both of you like a little rotary
phone laying on my bed with my feet up
right then i would like switch back and
forth between cause hold on you're not
gonna believe what tim just said jack
let me click over real quick we click
over oh man we're all right i'm so glad
i was able to patch this up between you
guys we had like a little mediation
before the show yeah exactly right we
all held hands in heaven no and all in
all actuality the last time jack was
here we had this debate over you know
family and mandate and government and
politics and uh i think the response was
was brilliant it was just a lot of
people either agreeing with one or the
other i got a bunch of messages saying
tim you saw the touch or tim i agree
with you and i saw similar things about
jack but it was a really great
conversation went viral
and so that's that's good that's that's
that's
you know
we don't see that
between
the the cult right the establishment
narrative it's it's it's in stone it's
static it can't be moved but here we
have these conversations even when we
get heated and then we have more we come
back we do it again yeah it was a
conversation that people needed to hear
people want to hear it i got literally
hundreds of emails
thousands of tweets at me and uh you
know i gotta say that everyone that said
something in public was kind of snippy
but everybody that sent me something in
private was very heartfelt and so it's
just clearly a debate that's ongoing and
a lot of people are dealing with it yeah
i was i was surprised like how i was
like well amazing it was epic let me
introduce myself in case anybody forgot
who i was i'm jack murphy and we're
doing this really cool thing called jack
brunch we're traveling around the
country we're having brunches on sunday
afternoon right after church good we
scheduled at one o'clock so sheamus you
come after church come after mass and uh
we had one in chicago and we just had
one in jersey city we didn't do it in
new york city why vax mandates
so we did it in jersey city we had an
amazing turnout we're doing one in tampa
on the 10th and one in nashville on the
24th austin after that check it out
jackbrunch.com hope to see you guys
there also mark it down
february 27th that's right washington
d.c i'm committed the final stop on the
tour is going to be lit jackpots.com we
also got james coughlin that's right
that's my real he just deadnamed me
i was like i'm gonna go with an edgy
weird performer name and we changed it
to sheamus jimmy mcnamara good old jimmy
mac that's what like half my cousins are
named uh what almost everyone in chicago
is called we were talking about this
before the show am i going to spoil the
um the cast castle if i let people know
what the conversation was oh that was
we'll let them watch it oh that was the
green room okay well anyway i'm seamus
coghill and of freedom tunes happy to be
here with my illinois boys this was uh
put together on late notice somebody
tweeted me saying at sheamus at jack
look i saw this sign while i was
traveling that said illinois on it
reminded me of the illinois boys i was
like we're getting back together here we
are here band is back together
that's right i've been giddy about it
for about 24 hours had to restrain
myself from tweeting it out until about
10 minutes ago we wanted it to be a
little bit i noticed that you actually
dressed and yeah this time i did and
you're actually wearing pants yeah but
don't think too deeply into it my
pajamas are dirty
yeah this is my this is my last case
scenario i wear jeans
i went to uh you know i went to ian's
room and tell him that sheamus was
coming back with with jack and you know
he was you know sitting in his yoga pose
levitating in the middle of his room
light emitting from his eyes and i was
like it was a loud
and i'm like yeah
like through the void i could hear him
and then i was like shave his back and
then he lands
when the light fades and he's like oh
cool
i gotta jump in the shower
i'm the only personal shower for it's
lovely
how about how about i shower today how
about uh we'll get into the news before
we get started we've got a sponsor my
friends we have biotrusts amazing
eternal reds just go to
drinkrightfeelwell.com you can get 51
percent off of your supply of eternal
reds what is this it is a powdered and
pulverized blend of eight super fruits
beets and berries with 250 milligrams of
vitamin c so if you're if you're not
getting those
super foods those veggies those fruits
good vitamins you get this stuff it's
really amazing you know what how i view
it it's kind of like we're talking about
like like like what do you call flavor
healthy kool-aid yeah yeah it's like i
just mixed it into my water we actually
made a special little cocktail with
before and i i feel amazing i think it's
the vitamin c to be honest i mixed it
into my water and without even thinking
i sucked it all down i mean it's just so
good it's delicious i think but you know
for me it's like you get more vitamin c
you're getting the vitamins you're not
getting so if that's if you want to be
healthier you go to
drinkrightfeelwell.com 51 off and
biotrust says you get a 60-day
money-back guarantee free shipping on
every order over fifty dollars in gifts
with every order and for every order
today biotrust donates a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you also get free vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
their new e-report for free the top 11
foods that boost circulation and again
51 off over at drink right feel well
guys i'm a big fan of biotrust you
probably realize we have three different
products we care from them because we
actually like all of them
the collagen we do the the keto stuff we
do that was like you know they came to
us like what do you think about it well
that's really cool we got sent this
sample and we immediately we have chris
who's the executive editor for
timcast.com he's a bartender so he made
this mocktail with his healthy drink and
i'm like dude i would love to shout this
out this is awesome and i'm just i'm
grateful to them for sponsoring a show
especially considering all the political
riffraff and and craziness so seriously
thank you biotrust i gotta say every
time i crack the bag open and take a big
breath of it it just feel it in my lungs
it's so good michael mouse was on the
show and he's just a uh you know he's a
beacon of of insight and he said when
we're doing one promo he's like guys
like these are the companies that are
supporting the free thought the free
that's true these are the companies you
need to be supporting if you're going to
be you know looking for any kinds of
products like this but don't forget
go to timcast.com become a member we'll
have a member segment coming up around
11 or so pm plus
man we've got so much going on because
of your support we've got two
non-profits because we're not in this
for the bucks we're in this for the
mission so we've got one one is going to
be about fact checking and doing
journalism fat checking the fact
checkers one is building network
technology that is open source and free
that can allow people to have make a
living and connect with the social
network decentralized uh so with your
support of temca.com this is what we're
funding you know we're we're absolutely
trying to build things outside of the
for-profit model even though we should
be we should be capitalists i think
we're doing well but we want to give
back we want to make something that's
long lasting so again timcast.com but
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends all right now that
we're done with all of that let's read
news
the audience can practically repeat that
verbatim verbatim
it's funny you were mentioning uh fact
checkers and earlier you were also
mentioning
that migrants were not being tested or
being allowed into the country without
being tested for covid and we're we have
different styles i didn't say that oh no
no i said they don't have a vaccine
mandate a vaccine edit that's right
that's right some of them are i got that
no so i got that tangled because
i was reading a snopes article which
rated the claim false that illegal
immigrants are being let into the
country without covet testing it says
mostly false and then when you read the
section that says what's true at the
bottom it says there are also many
reports of lack of testing in ice
detention centers so like they literally
are letting people in i mean they find a
way to spin it the way they spin it is
well they're not behind the surge in
cases across the country which isn't the
claim that they say they're debating we
had we had jorge and sagnek on the other
day who were literally down at the
border who literally stand in front of
these people and say were you tested and
they go no
like why would they be but it's it's you
know that that specific issue and we'll
get to this story in a second is border
patrol agents have a vax mandate and
these the people who are just entering
the country illegally like yeah well and
also like all right the entry is doing
fine i guess like the idea that you
could just adequately test 220 000
people per month pouring over the border
that's incredibly difficult like no
one's going to happen
yeah exactly
this country's busted well let's let's
read about this uh over at forbes we got
the story
biden's vax mandate to be enforced by
fining companies seventy thousand
dollars to seven hundred thousand
dollars
yo yo biden declared this by edict
fourteen thousand dollar fine per
infraction now it's seventy and if it's
a willful repeated infraction 700
thousand dollars insane
is this is this got passed in that
twenty five hundred dollars is this
particular 500 page bills in the 3.5
trillion dollar spending okay that's i
feel like they are deceiving us to pass
laws now that they are now
really as of this moment yeah they've
been doing it but now i feel like that's
a little crazy that was that was um no
conspiracy theories here guys they're
sneaking it in
snope says that's false ian yeah you
know so but this is this is the this is
the the you know when i see ian say
something like this i see this cherub
little face and these bright eyes being
like the government wouldn't lie to us
to pass yeah i'm the normie getting the
light bulbs going on right that's my
point right i mean with respect like
we've been watching them do this crazy
stuff forever they the 5 000 page
omnibus bill where it's just like nobody
knows what's in this i think it should
be a federal offense to vote on
something you don't read as a
representative i agree
yep you want to pass but then they
couldn't make their bills thousands of
pages long oh they could they just
couldn't vote on it okay so this is an
actual piece of legislation that's
before the congress at this moment in
time oh they voted they've um oh
actually i don't know if they voted on
yet they voted at the rate to spend the
debts the debt limit right so this is
one of what is going to go through
reconciliation or whatever i don't know
what all the parliamentary processes are
but at least
at least this is going before congress
right so at least this is something that
our representatives are uh allegedly
voting on that they have some knowledge
of their voting on this and we can count
on them right no i'm not saying this is
a good thing but i'm saying it's just
slightly different than the cdc mandates
right like or the osha yeah the osha
mandates like this is actually going to
be a law which makes it 10 times worse
because it actually legitimizes it
because our representatives are going to
vote on it and then it will actually
become a legitimate law look within
reason i'm okay with the legislature
being like we have decided we'll pass
this law but that's not what's happening
here what's happening here is the
democrats are like
you know normally this wouldn't pass
because you'd have opposition from
republicans but it's a spending bill so
uh
we're gonna just slide
whatever into this 2000 465 65-page bill
that no one's going to read and then
journalists started reading it and then
all sudden they're like whoa you want to
find people seven hundred thousand
dollars for not test mandating vaccines
in the workplace and this is for a
hundred employees or more this is for
every company for anybody that hires
anybody a lot of people are about to
have 99 employees right oh yeah i mean
just think about it you have an hr
department not there you spend them off
into a subsidiary hr company like you
were saying jack a lot of people are
going to hire like indian citizens uh
people from
wherever in the world that's not the
united states because it doesn't fall
under the same sort of mandates right i
mean if you want to ask me i would then
open up a business overseas i would live
here in the united states i'd domicile
it overseas i'd have all the
intellectual property over there and i'd
have that company hire people from
wherever remotely and what do you know
i'm not even an american company anymore
well jack i think that's un-american of
you well it's certainly i think you
should just stay here and let the
government do whatever they want just
bend over dude take that sword right off
the wall
that is that is link's master sword okay
it is for defeating ganon
what are you going to do if ganon comes
up here yeah you're not going to be
making jokes about the sword i'm going
to throw ian down right in front of him
yeah yeah i'm a pariah i tweeted
something out i got i got this is
interesting i tweeted i tweeted a
question and i got a ton of retweets i
said it was mask mandates then vax
mandates what comes after the vaccine
mandates
booster mandates so i saw some snarky
response to you it was uh the end of the
the end of the uh the pandemic that was
oh yeah no i i said they're gonna let us
go they're gonna let it's gonna be fine
you have 15 days to slow the spread and
then what so i was at the airport and i
was taking my shoes off to go through
security and i thought to myself wait
hold on just one more person i was
taking off my shoes and my belt and my
jacket to go through with security when
the guy noticed i had a small shampoo
bottle and a bottle of water so i went
to go throw it away and then he found
nail clippers and then i was being
detained and asked me questions and did
you you know i was trying to think like
it's always been this way right it's
always yeah it's always well
you you used to no you never could just
get on a plane before yeah no you always
had to do that that's what uh you know i
guess in 20 years they'll be saying the
same thing and you know they've thwarted
so many potential terror attacks the tsa
totally all the time about as many
droplets have that have been prevented
from spewing
the droplets but hold on there is
something after vex mendix what is it
it's the it's the passport
so once so here's what's going to happen
here's my prediction
well youtube just announced you know and
we'll get into those we'll maybe talk
about a bit more censorship in a minute
but they announced they're banning all
this anything it's anti-vaccine or
whatever because they go through they
they take routes this the establishment
whether intentional or not this is the
way authoritarianism flows routes that
are reasonably hard to disagree with so
like
vaccines well most people are like
they're good so they use that as a path
towards you know the these the special
interests politicians corrupt
individuals over time just a natural
pressure will start to impose
restrictions but you don't want the
average person is like well i'm not
against vaccines right so they accept
we all get vaccinated like bill maher
said he's the perfect example i took one
for the team that's what he said and i'm
like well that's you should go to a
doctor i mean you shouldn't just because
your friends told you to let's see
here's what's gonna happen do you guys
remember when um
famous libertarian robbie suave tweeted
that
if there was a if there was a choice
between masks and uh or a business with
a mass manager or a vaccine manager i
would choose the vaccine mandate because
i'm already vaccinated
and a lot of iuw types people like
quoted this and said this is exactly
what we're saying
it's not unreasonable to get vaccinated
most people are like okay i'll do it so
you get someone like bill maher saying
sure why not then once everybody has it
98 like biden says they're going to say
just get the app the app's easier you
lost your card you get the app it's no
big deal you just get the app it's easy
and then you're like well i mean i'm
already vaccinated so it's going to be
easy i just okay i'll find i'll just
download the app and then i got the app
and then and then
the mandates don't go away the ideas of
the businesses don't go away and then
you have the health app and then all
they have to do is roll out updates they
have the real estate they have the
precedent and they can roll out any
update they want whenever they want and
one day you'll open the app and it'll be
like did you get your new you know mdc5
you know checkup
and vaccine and you're like i don't know
what that is and then alert will pop up
saying go to the doctor now to be in
compliance you have one week and people
will be like okay
that's that's the precedent
yeah did you guys see that propaganda on
twitter where it's like on twitter
yes yes believe it or not is nothing
sacred anymore what like i just was
noticing that every time i went to
search all it was was the same image of
biden's plan is recommended by thank you
it was there for like for like days yeah
there was a law professor who said did
anybody notice this weird like thing on
everyone's homepage that says legal
experts say biden's plan is lawful
according to precedent which is what you
have to tell people all the time when
you're doing something illegal right
look everything i'm doing is perfectly
legal if you have to say that repeatedly
it's probably a good sign this law
professor was like this is
disinformation like it's not true and
twitter and it was really funny because
it was like you know kind of ian was
like they're passing laws by lying to us
this guy was like
am i am i just now realizing what's
going on
has this been happening before
and i'm like dude that's sweet twitter
once put up on their what's recommended
page for like a week a story about me
stealing a cat which was completely made
up wait i didn't know about that yeah
they said you stole a cat and that was
twitter's story for a week twitter had
on the what's happening like tim poole
accused of stealing cat i'm like it's
fake it's not real these things aren't
true but people just to that for i have
no idea why twitter and that it was
amazing like it just you know look it's
way funnier when it's someone you know
too just like that but look look look
it's it's it's funny and how absurd it
is but think about a law professor i
mean maybe this is good news he's like
all of a sudden going like wait a minute
they're lying to me it's like oh you
just figured that out mm-hmm we need
more people to figure that out emergent
awareness
that's i think that's what people have
been saying like they were funneling
towards an inevitability and that that
inevitability is the awakening of our
conscience who says that his name is
something wood he said he was like a cia
ancient i think he might be like a a bs
artist i don't trust some truth oh bs
artist but i like what he said twitter
exactly what was his name something was
the one that said tim stole a cat he was
like a guy that the cia would have well
he according to him the cia had him like
doing secret operations in the 90s and
stuff and he said part of it was that
this uh operation looking glass i think
is what it's called a project looking
glass and yellow book and they would try
and like
remote view the possible futures and
then
that's in stargate too well it's a
stargate program as well yeah stargate
was the government so he's saying you
watched stargate and thought it was real
both no no no
stargate was actually they were trying
to do psychic experiments in the army
yeah and apparently
as around 2012 things started to
converge and they can't really see any
other possible future than this one that
we're headed towards which is
singularity awakening of consciousness
or but they're preparing for the other
reality of like are we gonna have to
live underground because of some
holocaust on the on the surface like
some horrible solar flare yeah or or
yeah whatever firestorm or whatever i
don't i don't know about all that i mean
that's that's you see we were talking
about like
the establishment politicians lying to
us and then ian just like the awakening
like you're saying about 100 it's
because of the times beyond this
emergent awakening is like inevitable
like trump woke people up in a way that
like was uncomfortable i was bringing it
back so it's 20 minutes 20 minutes ago
ian was like wait a minute maybe
politicians lie to us now he's like the
cia has this thing where they're putting
people in this that's how the rabbit
starts one step you're taking one step
here's what you guys need to understand
is right when we're sitting here talking
and we're going through a conversation
ian calculates very quickly
everything we're saying and so to
someone who doesn't understand i mean
this sincerely to someone who doesn't
like you can't know what ian's thinking
when he all of a sudden says the cia
program there was a thought process
where he was like the lies the
manipulation people have have come out
speaking out against it and then ian
jumps into
emerging you know i must have fallen
down a wormhole here because ian said
something crazy and then tim not only
defends it but explains it and
rationalizing i know it doesn't just
start screaming instead of going no no
ian
it must be your moderating influence
that's what i do here championships
i help misinformation you know what i
think it really is i think it's that you
know sheamus and jack have been in uh
imbibing some fine 40 or scotch in there
just they don't realize they're just
they're inebriated so they can't realize
this is normal
i don't feel any tension basically
no don't you dare is there a roofie in
here i am i am a good host who have who
has provided a 40-year single malt
school
and i got to just make one comment too
uh i noted in your um you know liquor
cabinet two weeks ago that you had this
incredible gin the botanist 22 year old
gin it's like you know i really love a
good aviation just like an old-timey
drink with uh creme de viole head in
there
and i come back two weeks later and not
only is there creme de violette but
there's an actual bartender behind the
bar saying sir would you would you like
an aviation he's actually the executive
editor of timcast.com i don't need to
know that i don't need to know that i
just need to know that i had a very
tasty aviation which is a really faint
fine drink yeah yeah so this is this is
this you know you know why this is a
good conversation because we're not
wallowing in in pity and self-defeat
because we're watching this let's get
back to that no that's two three drinks
from now it's two drinks right now i
don't know do you guys feel how do you
feel optimistic pessimistic and let me
just preface this with uh we had dr
robert murphy on economist smart guy
and man that conversation was brutal he
was like oh wait robert murphy murphy
nice to meet you my other cousin yeah
yeah
check it out he said
the reserve requirements for banks to
give out loans has been removed because
of covid and then i was just like
there's no reserve requirement no
they did it like on a friday night at 10
so there's not even a fractional reserve
anymore it's a no reserve system now
just present
literally just fraud it's literally just
fraud that's what that's called fraud
you're just loaning out a bunch of money
you don't have that that explains why
the reverse repo rate is like 1.2
trillion dollars daily now what does
that mean uh it's where like the banks
and the fed like swap securities and
swap money in order to back up the fact
that they've loaned out all their money
and don't have anything on the books
which is actually good for the economy
in the long term i hear yeah is that
right it's really good yeah that's
really good yeah the economy being gold
bitcoin land yes no that's true i mean
i'm not going to give financial i was
about to give myself financial advice
but there's a little sheet here that
tells me not to get financial that's not
true
no no no no no no but you almost work
for goldman sachs so i'm saying that
that's true no no no no you can give
financial advice it's just you're
legally like you're bound no that's
reliable
uh financial advice i mean
you can give financial advice legal
advisor medical advice but then you're
liable for like you know someone will be
like sheamus told me to take the form
would it be the stream that it was set
on would also become liable so like
there's chains of liability if you start
doing it no no basically you're going to
go back to your business what we try to
tell people is like when we're talking
about bitcoin and stuff make sure you're
like i'm not advising you on anything
yeah that's on you
yeah i will i didn't say anything then
before the show we were talking about
doing a bit i was like what if we just
like make up a bunch of random
ingredients to say in the vaccine just
off the top of our heads that would be
great for tim's channel it's like
flintstones
so i guess it wasn't that good of a bit
you know it's like i felt the tension in
the room over here tim was like no
i will shoot you these guys are all
drunk
what i'm so who's you know
i'm way more optimistic today than i was
yesterday i realized last night that i
thought i'd been building out the
fetavers because we've been working on
this decentralized social media app
basically that's going to comb connect
people what we're really building is the
metaverse which is ultimately artificial
intelligence augmented reality finance
and social media conglomerating and do
it like a internet 3.0 but we're
starting with we're building the first
leg of it which is the feta versus
social social media aspect decentralized
self-sustaining social media tools for
people who want to run their own you
know have their own internet presence in
any capacity it's going to be epic and
other people are building the other legs
as we're doing it and i'm finding today
that people are contacting me and then
we're we're merging you know software
this is why crypto is so important right
now just i want everyone to remember
exactly jack's reaction when he was like
there's no reserve requirement for banks
i had not heard that the price of
bitcoin went up when he said that
here's the crazy thing too like we
talked about this with with bob murphy
the m1 money supply
you can watch it just go forward and
they just like skyrockets and everyone
always goes tim you're wrong they just
changed the definition of how they
define money supply and then you look
after they change the definition and
it's skyrocketing in like a
80 degree angle and i'm like yo
this is why all the ultra wealthy people
are buying properties sight unseen in
places like west virginia and idaho
you know let me just say real quick just
one point
if you've been tracking the real estate
market i don't know if you've seen this
jack i'm calling agents because we're
like we want to expand we need more
space and the stories i'm hearing
agent says i got a call the other day
they said i'll take it and i was like do
you want to have a meeting do you need
finance i'm like no i said i'll take it
and they're like do you want to see it
no i said i'll take it where do i wire
the money like that because people who
live in these big cities who have cash
no the cash is worthless and they're
like i need to get this in something
it's a guarantee land lands a guarantee
for the most part
i gotta go yeah no but then the question
is so i think we would all agree that
inflation inflation is occurring and is
going to get worse but the question is
will the real estate bubble outpace
inflation
people got to live somewhere yeah so i
think yes what i think it will i think
there could be a crash
but
if i'm not i'm not a financial expert
look if you if you just value
the land in terms of dollars you get you
have a fixed amount of land yeah and you
get more dollars well it's just going to
go up in dollar value yeah yeah but if
it's a bubble though and that bubble
pops and then the property's worth
significantly less right so so like the
bubble in 2008 was was because uh there
was lacks underwriting standards you
could get loans if you had no income you
had no assets you could lie about
everything ninja loans etc so that was a
bubble created through a lack of
underwriting and regulatory oversight
and stuff this is just straight price
inflation because there's just more
money chasing a fixed amount of product
and so you are giving me financial
advice i am just talking about economics
that's it
i'm i'm thinking it's the same thing you
know i'm looking at crypto i'm looking
at crypto prices i'm looking at the
manipulation of the crypto market i'm
just thinking my attitude is man do i do
not want to have us dollars yeah
i went on a rock and stone frenzy and
bought a bunch of opals and i was like
wow have you ever looked at an opal it's
silica silicon dioxide and water because
they always save itself if you're going
to invest what are you talking about if
you're going to invest your money
invested in gold silver jewels like gems
gems are legit because i don't know
something about looking into a gem like
a really unique gem man that is
transformed please don't let that be
your finances in the land but i was like
land or gems well let's do both well i'm
giving you a hard time because you
caught me very off guard there i've
never heard someone say that they're
like investing in gems i was like oh i'm
investing in jail i didn't realize that
after i was doing it i will say maybe to
that yeah assuming the system exists and
inflation happens then the value of
these items will go up along with the
value of most items buy for 80 bucks
selling
there's nothing like it on earth and you
know what i don't think people are
rushing for that the way they are for
gold or silver exactly orlando so i
laughed it ian but but now i got a lot
i want everyone to just remember it's
going to be in like five years you're
going to be on the side of the road
going like these hooples and ian's going
to walk up with a shot
a shiny suit encrusted and opal spinning
his opal cane and he's going to be like
i got your opponent right your 50 bucks
contain up to 30 water
and you'll drink that let's pay for that
yeah you can see it like refracts
through the the silicon dioxide okay
meanwhile meanwhile wealthy elites are
buying up land like crazy yeah because
if you know we had max kaiser on the
show he said he said inflation was what
fourteen percent
what they're telling us is five percent
yeah fourteen percent so it's just like
you to invest it in something you got to
put it somewhere
but if that's the case buy a brand new
car
yeah
i'm sorry sheamus man
it's almost i got to say like ian's opel
thing kind of makes sense
brand new all right they're only going
to go up in value
i don't i don't know like what would you
guys think a regular a regular person
should do i mean how much how much does
the average person have in savings a few
hundred bucks well that's a good
question our economy has actually been
designed over the past 50 years to
disincentivize savings so most people
don't and they'll come out here with
these
you know
the left will tote these studies and the
right doesn't discuss it as often but
the left will tote these studies saying
oh the average person doesn't have
enough saved up to get them through an
emergency if one occurs
and that's true what they don't point
out is that is not the result of
inadequate social welfare spending the
reason for that is because we are
constantly inflating our currency and
people know that their money isn't going
to be worth as much in the future as it
is today so you actually alter their
time preference and make them more
likely to spend in the moment the idea
behind this is that stimulates the
economy but of course what you're doing
is taking from the future because people
aren't saving as much yeah they're not
and they're also not learning to defer
their appetites which is a really
important part of having a civil society
and i thought you were just the cartoon
guy yeah i know he said murphy thought i
was an idiot he's like
he still does but he thought i said that
nice come on bobby murphy so you're
preaching temperance
yeah it's a big part of it it is a
virtue yeah we talked about virtues is
that the other one what do you think is
here i'm just going to say this i know
that personally
i don't really have expensive tastes
besides the stuff tim pays for you know
um so i save a lot of my money no i mean
i'm serious i don't really have
expensive tastes i save a lot of my
money and now i'm looking i'm saying
like for the past five years i've i've
lived beneath my means and basically
saved everything and that hasn't done as
much good for me as i thought it could
have i should have been spending that
stuff on assets that would increase in
value over time well you don't spend on
assets yeah you're right you invest
but the thing is even if i was just
buying stupid short-term pleasures in
some ways if inflation gets bad enough
that almost would have been better right
because you know you won't be able to
afford it with that what if you have
money what if you bought a house
at you know 3.5 or something yeah or or
5
and inflation's at 14. no yeah exactly
exactly so
so here's the thing i don't understand
right like i understand how they
manipulate the cpi i understand how they
back out goods and services that are
going up because they want to get to
core cpi understand how they don't
account for productivity gains i
understand how they gain that system but
the one system that doesn't get gamed is
the deepest most liquid market in the
world which is the bond market right and
the bond market right now says that you
can borrow money at 30 years
i think it's what like five percent or
less and so that person who is willing
to borrow or loan you that money
all this millions and billions of
dollars is willing to loan you that
money for 30 years
i don't know what the fixed rate is
right now but i think it's like five
percent or less at five percent so the
most sophisticated people in the world
with the most amount of money with the
most at risk
with the most on the line really
hedge fund managers pension fund
managers all these people they're
willing to invest that money for 30
years at less than five percent which
means that they don't think that
inflation is real
maybe or maybe it's a machine
maybe there's there's
there's a sort of mechanization how
these systems go and most people just go
along with it
you've seen the movie the big short well
yeah i have but just one more thought on
that like the financial markets are
meant to be efficient which is not
always true they're meant to have
processed all available information
which is not always true as well and
these are the most sophisticated players
most making the most sophisticated
decisions
yeah and and the way that the 30-year
interest rate is composed right it has a
risk premium and it has inflation
expectations in there
so uh you've seen the big short i sure
have i lived in the big short amazing
movie i was in real estate then i was in
fixed income people people knew that
people knew this was was bunk it was
broken it wouldn't make sense but they
didn't care the machine was was chugging
along well i think they thought
yeah and i think people assume i can
still pull money out of a broken system
in the short term so i'll throw
something into it and i'll just get out
before it crashes they think they're
gonna be able to do that right but when
you're loaning money away for 30 years
you're locking yourself in for 30 years
this is a guy these are people that have
billions and billions and billions of
dollars and they're like i'm gonna give
it to you for 30 years and you only have
to pay me five percent five percent
total on the on the capital on the yes
wow so there's no built-in inflation
expectation in long-term interest rates
well hold on which is peculiar if you
hold a hundred dollars
and inflation happens and you lose
buying power
you lose if you lend out 100 bucks and
then 30 years later right well they only
pay you five percent but if inflation's
10 you're losing either way but it's
still better but it's still better than
just holding on to the money right but
there are these people are very smart
there are inflation assets that respond
well to inflation like really and they
probably do have investments
i think it's a way to hedge your bets
it's like a little bit of a safer way
even even though you don't get as much
of a return i think what we're saying
here is that the bond market is
inefficient that's the only conclusion
we can be coming to i don't think you
know i think people need to understand
what money means to to billionaires into
these these
even high millionaires means never
having to say you're sorry they don't
think about a hundred thousand dollars
they don't think about a couple hundred
thousand dollars no you you think they
do they don't it's acceleration it's a
form of acceleration i've i've i've been
to uh um lasagne is that the name of the
city right in switzerland
i have been in the penthouse suite of a
billionaire and it was just like they
have this 50 million dollar swiss swiss
property that they just don't care about
sure but then it was like it's an asset
it's gaining in value right they're fine
with that yeah so so when they're
looking at bonds they're probably like
gotta invest in something
it's better than holding cash it's true
it's entirely possible but it is the
most liquid the most the deepest and
meant to be the most efficient market on
the planet
so it's meant to reflect the sum total
wisdom of all the financial players in
the world it's not they're not that wise
look how 2008 turned out yeah they're
not that wide that's probably it i'm not
disputing again i'm gonna get in trouble
with this i was asking you questions
about we're not disagreeing i was asking
you questions about millie last week you
know or last time and people like you
should have heard the way jack was
shilling for millie he's a traitor i was
like dude i was just asking some
questions about that command chain of
command and by the way the very next day
i had on cash patel the chief of staff
of the department of defense and asked
him those questions in particular to get
the whole thing out there but uh no it's
just fascinating to me to see that maybe
the financial system is broken so like i
think that's what if you could take a
loan a bond loan of a million dollars
and then invest that at five percent
invest that into something and then
double your money well no that's the guy
that's the smart guy you're on the other
side you're saying i want to borrow five
percent heck yeah i'll borrow they're
just loaning out at five percent because
they have access to infinite no they
don't these are these are private
individuals these are institutions these
are pension funds that are investing
their money in say you know the united
states government right all these people
are loaning the united states government
money at less than five percent for 30
years
knowing that they're going to take a
bath i don't know i don't know
maybe it's an illusion i don't know all
of it is just kind of like all i know is
i'm i'm i'm getting more real estate i
have real estate
yeah wait no i didn't just say that
smart because that might be construed as
financial advice and i would never give
it to you look we're we're expanding
we're buying land and maybe it's a
bubble i really don't care um the last
thing i want to do watching the so so
the m1 money supply spiked because they
said savings are unrestricted now
savings accounts used to have limits you
could only transfer a certain a certain
amount of time that's right we talked
about got rid of that and so i was i was
at a bank recently and they were like do
you want to open a savings or checking i
was like does it matter and they're like
well i mean
it doesn't matter anymore oh you know
what i just noticed that i transferred
money out of my savings account and
usually it says you can only transfer
five times a month or whatever and it
didn't say that dude you're right they
removed they removed the the gates that
were restricting the flow and now it's
just
unleashed and rich people are snatching
up assets like crazy and poor people are
going to be left holding an empty box
this is what we were saying was going to
happen years ago right i mean i i did a
cartoon about this
rich people got all the money from the
belt they got these incredibly low
interest loans or no interest loans and
then what they were able to do is buy up
all the assets from small businesses
that shut down because they had to go
through the sba which was processing
over the course of two weeks what
they're used to processing over an
entire year or like 10 times used to
processing over an entire year so a
bunch of small businesses shut down the
millionaires and billionaires are able
to buy all that stuff up yep and then we
end up with a massive consolidation of
corporate power we need to tax the one
percent and so it goes and and
they made this problem and look at the
lockdowns the destruction of the small
business
and now they're saying we're going to
find you you know these aren't these are
still technically small businesses with
100 employees but now they're coming
after you i mean it is legit
but there's so many weird forces that
work too like right now if you've got a
renter in your property and they're not
paying rent you can't kick them out so
imagine all the pro you can't yeah that
ended the sea the cdc the supreme court
issued a new
ruling and said but either way the
second time biden came out yeah you
could have still evicted and and
so so i'm hearing these stories of
people like biden said you have to get a
vaccine it's like him saying something
means nothing you'll go to a court and
the court's gonna courts will side with
the supreme court's decision so when the
supreme court says you can't do it it's
illegal he can say it you go to court
you'll be like your honor i'll cite the
supreme court and they'll be like okay
agreed right finance awards are
meaningful so so you're saying right now
officially the foreclosure thing is done
it's gone yes it really just depends on
your jurisdiction there's probably local
judges who are going to be like i'm
going to say no you can't do victims but
the supreme court said it said it twice
right interesting but let's talk about
the state of this country yeah we got
the story from timcast.com
rnc sues two vermont towns for allowing
non-citizens to vote the governor's veto
of the measure was overruled by the
state's legislature they say montpellier
and winooski recently altered their uh
charters so non-citizens who immigrated
legally could vote in municipal
elections how's that for you have no
country that's like the opposite
direction of where i want to go i want
you to have to live there for four years
before you can start voting there so
wait wait at least could you be a
citizen first yeah you gotta be a
citizen and have some residence in the
area where you're voting wait can you
please say that to me one more time did
you just tell me that there are
jurisdictions in the united states where
it is now legal to vote if you're not a
citizen yes there are many actually
there's a lot of them i think
sacramento's got a couple san francisco
got a couple those are those are
municipal elections
so there's like school board and stuff
like that yeah look look
the left will come out and be like it
used to be in this country you had to be
a landowner to vote those yeah bigots
and it's like
let me just let me just let's just break
this down real quick you're in the
middle of the woods there's a bunch of
people walking around and you're like
all right we're gonna have a vote on
what to do about that tree that fell
down and then a bunch will walk up and
they're like i'd like to vote do you
live here yes where do you live um
okay look only the people who live here
get to vote oh that's racist you're
bigoted it's like
the reason they did it that they had
that system was because
if you lived there you voted but now you
see like matt walsh just poked a big
hole in that did you see he wanted to go
speak a lot i think it's loudoun county
and then they wouldn't let him because
he wasn't a resident so he rented
property and he's like now i'm a
resident but it's like okay he's showing
that you really should have to live
there for like four years
a long period i've actually looked into
this a few times now i want to have more
clarification i'm gonna tell one story
real quick we've been looking at
jurisdictions to buy land maybe
jurisdictions with not a lot of people
in them yeah that have sheriff's offices
and school boards and stuff so maybe we
move enough people there we take over
our sheriff's office right how cool
would that be
so a lot of these jurisdictions they the
the um
the requirement for voting is that you
have moved there with the intention of
remaining that's it
now you're telling me that these could
be non-us citizens yes
just foreigners that showed up came to
the meeting and said i'm here now i
would like to vote
yes
are they renting property is that the
montpellier bill allows what is defined
as a legal resident of the united states
to be able to vote in city elections if
someone is here on a permanent basis why
would he or she not want to participate
in the process to become a citizen okay
so they have to have a green card i
guess it says legal immigrants yes i see
it doesn't matter as far as i'm
concerned right they're still not u.s
citizens you have to be a u.s citizen
yes exactly yeah
the idea that you shouldn't have no i
know it's really insane really simple
they er they're they they are
you know i got a friend
argue all the time because he was just
all on board for biden
he goes on twitter he goes on facebook
he's screaming trump is bad we gotta
vote for biden and then guess what he
did it a couple months after the
election ended he moved to europe
that is the problem when people are like
everyone please vote for this thing and
then as soon as it happens they're like
later suckers
wow now we're watching this this this
free fall economic crisis labor
shortages gas prices inflation the
border afghanistan and the people who
vote for it at least this one guy is
like i'm out
later [ __ ] yeah thanks appreciate it
i kind of get the idea of a locality
maintaining its autonomy and if like if
they want to let foreign citizens vote
in local locale then do it who's to say
you can't you know but so maybe it
should be on a space but i can imagine
someone getting in there and co-opting
it and being like yes now we can all yes
people are like no well pretty here's
here's the issue ian you've got 10
people who live in a house and they all
just they won't they want to vote for
what's what's for lunch they all pitch
in every day they put a dollar in the
lunch bucket and so they're like okay
it's lunch time we got ten dollars what
should we buy from and then someone says
well why don't we let you know jim he's
our neighbor he doesn't live here but he
can jimmy mack
jimmy
so what happens is jimmy mack then says
i would like to to vote that we allow my
my brother to vote as well and so let's
put it to a vote when you allow someone
from outside to vote on very specific
internal issues they will of course vote
for their own interest so when you say
non-citizens can vote they'll be like i
would like to vote in this election yes
i'd like to vote yes on allowing more
people who aren't citizens to vote
why wouldn't they people are going to
vote for what they think is best for
them it's kind of like community and
that metaphor would be like a house of
ten people and then like another guy
moves in an eleventh person who doesn't
his name's not on the lease but you give
him voting power he doesn't even move in
it's the delivery guy who drops off
lunch he's at the door and everyone's
like well we have to vote oh we have to
include him now we have eleven people
voting but this is people with green
cards that live there yeah in the in the
instance all right but if someone's not
a citizen there's less of a guarantee
that they're in it for the long run
let's let's guarantee that they're going
to be assisting try again there's ten
people in a big house and then you know
jimmy mack is sleeping on the couch
on the lease yeah he's on the lease we
don't know what his plan is he's just
crashing here half the people here are
really pissed off about it they're like
dude i pay rent i don't want some dude
what if i'm gonna have somebody over and
he's on the couch and then they're like
okay we all pooled our resources to buy
a dinner well he should he's here should
be allowed to vote on what we eat and
you're like oh come on and then what
happens is there is like there's a
meeting in the house and they say who
should be allowed to vote on what we eat
and then they're like we should allow
him to vote too it it it includes him
and then he says oh i got some friends
who are going to be hanging out uh i
think they should be allowed to decide i
mean they're going to be here too and
then in a few months all of a sudden
there's 15 people who don't live there
out voting the 10 who do
this is why we have
restrictions
not because we hate people or we we
oppose freedom or wear bigots it's
because we're literally like hey economy
means household management from the
greek economia so we're quite literally
talking about managing the household in
an effective way so that we are growing
not collapsing but when you allow people
who don't live to come in they're going
to be like uh i vote to eat his portion
and then they take it and they leave
so people need to have ties to the
community so yes you have to live there
for a certain amount of time or be a
citizen a legal resident is is what
they're talking about is eroding the
system you can live here but you're not
a citizen you want to become a citizen
you can go through the process
then you are a full-fledged member of
our community we're going to allow you
to stay so if someone wants to crash in
my house and sleep on the couch for a
little bit but a little bit that's fine
but they're not going to be voting on
what you know cable provider we're going
to be getting if they want to move in
put a deposit down pay rent we'll talk
about them being a full result or you
could say people with green cards have
to go through a different process other
than citizenship that will allow them to
vote in their local community as people
would say if you're not
i'm just saying if you're not a citizen
you should not be able to vote and it's
not as if
granting these people who are not
american citizens the right to vote in
any election is going to be the end of
it and the left is going to go okay they
have the adequate rights that we should
be giving to non-citizens they're just
going to keep pushing to give them more
voting power in other situations they'll
go oh see we allow them to vote in local
elections why not state elections why
not national elections right they do not
stop right the new federal requirement
for voting in the presidential election
will be are you eligible to vote in any
jurisdiction in america yep yeah and you
know uh and then when the republicans
are like we don't think this is good the
democrats are going to go right right
right
they're just suppressing voters voting
they're suppressing voter rights that's
exactly what dude it is absolutely
insane when you look at how far our
system of election has been eroded and
destroyed and now we're at the point
where there's universal mail in voting
which the left will tell you makes it
easier for everyone to vote it makes it
easier for a whole first of all
including people who shouldn't vote
let's let's i'm not gonna go there i'm
gonna tell you this
when you live in a city with extreme
population density two activists can hit
a thousand uh doors knocking on those
doors to advocate for their candidate
and a republican would require 10 times
the amount of distance and energy and
money to cover because they're rural and
they're spaced out that alone
should be a red flag as to why we need
some kind of standard uniform process
for voting that we actually assess what
i mean by that is it shouldn't be well
actually i should rephrase that it
shouldn't be just this blanket everyone
gets to do x because it doesn't affect
every area the same way money is used
differently in different jurisdictions
the reason why the democrats are so dead
set one of the reasons universal mail
and voting is not because and i know a
lot of people on the right get mad about
this
mass fraud or anything that that's not
it there's certainly issues a guy got
arrested at 300 bouts in the recall
action in his car he got charged with
forgery that stuff happens but one
activist for the democrats can go into
one apartment complex and secure a
thousand votes by advocacy which is
legal and normal but a republican in a
republican jurisdiction has to cover ten
square miles get the same amount of
people meaning no matter the republicans
want to spend 10 times the money or some
exponentially greater number to cover
that ground that system does not work
how about first pass the post voting
doesn't work we need ranked choice or a
different system i don't even know if
ranked choice is perfect but it's
probably better than what we got yeah it
is and then you have to go to a voting
station and there should be voting
stations set up per population so if
it's in a big city and it's for every
you know every 30 000 people you set up
a one voting station so that means in
dense areas you'll have 50 all within a
couple blocks and in rural areas you'll
have 15 within a couple blocks instead
of just saying we mail it to everybody
yep i was thinking do we do with one
person one vote and the rank choice kind
of automatically does that yeah one
person one vote makes no sense it's i
understand why you know the founders may
have thought that made sense back in the
day it's a very simple system but it
ultimately results in people being like
i have no choice but to vote for this
awful person
if you were able to actually be like
here are my values ranked out ranked
choice voting is better it's not perfect
there are still circumstances in which
people vote for the lesser of two evils
you know but i i i do think rank choice
makes more sense i think maine does it
this way i think i'm not sure maybe
nebraska there's a couple places that
are implementing ranked choice is this a
new development or is this something
that's been around for a while right
choice no the these non-us citizens
voting in localities so uh over the past
couple of years we've seen stories out
of you know california and new york
where they allow this and they say it's
just for like schools and things like
this it makes sense because they have
kids in the schools and you go oh okay i
guess that makes sense and the next day
they go look the kids are in the schools
they're using the streets they're
driving on buses they should have a say
in how taxes are being spent their kids
are already they already vote on the
school board one by one they will keep
pushing until eventually it's like how
long have you been here sir i just got
here 15 minutes ago from el salvador uh
here's your voter card and uh thank you
for choosing our president
yeah no well you know part of this comes
from the supreme court decision that
says that anybody that shows up on the
schoolhouse steps
must be educated
right did you know that one point in
time you had to be a citizen to get
educated interesting yeah now literally
anybody who shows up at the door
and can say can show that they live here
like here's my power bill or whatever
you mean at a public school though
probably yeah of course anybody taking
tax money any citizen no matter of
immigration status legal illegal
whatever you show up you get an
education you get fed school lunch
program participate in after school
activities all the things and you know
back in the day hundreds of years ago
there were no harshly controlled borders
you could walk on in to new york and
they'd be like are you citizen no and
they'd be like well then you can't work
here or you can't live here things like
that but you could basically move about
with little issue and now
i think people need to understand the
exponential growth and population and
what that really means it changes things
yes however the point was you could be
there and they'd be like look
we have citizens the reason they're
citizens is because we know who's a part
of the community who's pitching in who's
doing the work who's serving in who's
being conscripted who's in the fire
brigade
we can't have some strange person who's
not a part of this coming in and
changing what we do so they have these
rules i think people need to understand
though
the the scale of population growth there
were two million people in the colonies
at the time of the revolution there's
320 million now
i mean that is
it is insane
we see these massive protests yo
if an occupy wall street protest when
they had like you know 20 000 people
marching through the street
if that group of people were marching on
a battlefield they'd be like what great
country has such a mighty force
it's like oh that's just a bunch of
college kids who are bored
right
you know
oh so it'll be easy for us except for
their numbers
population growth has been absolutely
insane
yeah people don't you know what i was
thinking about too with population
growth stuff
you used to how many people did you know
back then hundreds of years ago when
there were barely any people you'd know
like 30 people well you also weren't
connected to everyone through the
internet too so you didn't know about
the people in the next town over on the
other coast or around yeah
so you didn't this this is one of the
impacts on the dating market actually is
that women can look in their phone and
look at all the the most attractive men
the most appealing men from every city
in america and vice versa yeah and so
they're like oh well i'm going to hold
out for that guy right but instead
there's all these sort of like decent
guys all around them like no i'm going
to get that guy over there who's in
california not to be the feminist in the
room but i've totally yeah you are i am
i've totally seen it go both ways though
where guys will be like all right i'm
going to look at these women on the
internet and i don't think there's
anything necessarily wrong with that if
you find someone who works better for
you and they're not in your community go
for it but let's break down what's
happening to women
you go on a dating app
they look at their messages and there's
like they've matched with everyone
they've chosen so they're on tinder
right and they're like ugly ugly
attractive ugly attractive ugly
attractive they close the app and then
goes
instantly three messages yeah so what's
happened to guys guys are swiping on
literally every woman yeah hoping that
one of them will like them in the
convention but they don't message back
so here's what we end up seeing the
internet age has created two forks
between the genders women
who can choose the most attractive men
even unattractive women this is crazy
the data from these dating apps shows
that even women who are considered to be
average or unattractive
still get the top tier guys yes so what
happens to a guy who's a seven out of
ten he's got a good career couldn't tell
you moderately attractive no no i can
tell you he goes on he goes on websites
looks like creepy crazy adult content
and then just isolates plays video games
and then thinks he's a sub human and
then he becomes the thing
no no
that's what i'm saying there are two
trees women are getting to choose anyone
they want and men are getting nothing
and so they become addicted to
creepy adult films and weird stuff and
then you get the hikikomori you guys
know what that is
yeah japanese kids people that stay in
their house they locked themselves in
their rooms there was a viral uh there's
there's the r slash tinder and there was
a message where someone like messaged a
woman or i think i don't think it was 10
i don't know what what it was cringe it
was a cringe thing on reddit and they
were like messaging women saying why why
do women shoes claim they want you know
um intelligent men but then shoes you
know really dumb built guys why won't
they spend time talking to us sub-humans
and things like that
there was this uh a story i read about
in cells involuntary celibates where
apparently some like journalists
actually found out they were all rather
average dudes they weren't subhuman they
weren't gross they weren't ugly they had
good careers but they thought they were
because they could not get a
relationship
this like this whole all this internet's
doing is making it it's it's polarizing
it's pulling up the extremes in
basically everything from politics to
dating to
economics i mean look at super stocks
look at the apes
everything is dialed up to 11 because of
the internet because of the speed of
communication yeah so here's i want to
throw this out there i agree with you
that the internet has accelerated a lot
of those very unfortunate social changes
but i would say that that's a product of
the sexual revolution and not the
internet itself the fact that people are
pursuing meaningless sexual
relationships and hooking up with other
people rather than trying to get married
and build families is a huge part of why
women will gravitate to a smaller
minority of men in a natural setting or
in a decent culture i should say
where people understand that the purpose
of sexuality is unity and procreation
and they want to get married and have
children you're looking for someone
who's going to be a stable marriage
partner and not necessarily the chad or
the stacy to use these terms and so if
you had the internet being used by
virtuous people to find a decent spouse
we wouldn't have this problem but what
happens is someone's just the woman may
be looking for a spouse to be honest but
the guys who match with her are not and
so then they end up having a lot of
meaningless sexual encounters and then
when they're older and of course there's
no meaningless sexual encounter right
there's some attachment that occurs and
then it breaks off and everyone's hurt
in some way and she ends up unhappy
because she doesn't find a long-term
partner she found some dudes who wanted
to use her body
and then you end up with like you said a
class of men who a lot of women won't
talk to because well they are pursuing
men who just want them for the short
term they're not looking at the guys who
actually would be interested in being
with them for the long term
it's tough um as somebody that's not
been in the dating market for for a
while like six or seven years i do
remember what it was like and
fortunately for me i'm tall i'm handsome
i'm successful i did not have that
experience i had the opposite experience
where there was a lot of opportunities
but i would talk to the women i would
like get their feedback you know and
they were all miserable all miserable
about it yeah and the whole setup i
don't i don't even know if people do
people even use those apps anymore i
mean like tinder yeah it's really
unfortunate yeah i use i started using
2013 as a social experiment for minds
because we were looking at implementing
dating software into the website kind of
like a chat roulette type thing and then
i kind of got addicted to it i actually
met a girl on okcupid we dated for three
years she's a good friend of mine to
this day and uh i still use it from time
to time but i feel so depressed and
dirty when i do and it's very
uneffective especially out in the out in
the country like this like the idea of
just like swiping on people like that
right it's such a quick decision yeah i
mean i'm i met my fiance we're getting
married uh next year i met her we've
been together over you know seven years
i met her on okcupid and what was great
about it is it was like a database i
could just be like i'm like this thing
and that's a little bit of this thing
you've seen this stuff back in the day
okay cupid was like you had a profile
yeah so
you go on and we we're starting to see
the emergence of these issues okay cuba
published a lot of data oh i saw they
mentioned they they actually deleted one
they had a story about in cells and ugly
men and they said if you're ugly you're
out of luck and then they took it down
okay cupid yeah yeah yeah well they did
a study where they found out based on
the way men and women were selecting
that men rate 50 of women as below
average and women rate something like 70
percent of men is below average yeah
right well there was this little known
fact too that okay keep it sorted you
into the good looking pile and the bad
looking
right so like if you if you got rated
highly enough they just put you in this
whole other category and all you saw
were other people that were highly rated
and so like i once started a second
account and like put up bad pictures of
yourself you uploaded pictures of me
right here like i started the second
account and i was like wait like oh i
thought that there was just nothing but
good-looking women on okay cupid and
then i started the second account i'm
like well actually that is not the case
someone actually requested that we build
dating software with the tim cast model
and i think maybe if we do like open
source so you see the algorithms not
forcing you to look at what it thinks
you look i
okay jack brunch come down on a sunday
afternoon after church there's like 50
dudes and a bunch of women but 50 dudes
you know that they're in like
masculinity they're into brotherhood
they're into sovereignty they're red
pilled they're fit they're strong they
make money they're well dressed and some
of them are single come on down
match make jackbrunch.com well this is
the other thing too even outside of the
internet unfortunately many of the
social avenues available for young
people are very nefarious and a lot of
that is because we don't have a
church-centered community in this
country anymore and so people will go
out to a bar or a club to meet someone
which is not necessarily where you're
guaranteed to meet a high quality person
who's going to be interested in a
long-term relationship
yeah i wonder what people's expectations
are and again i have lived like i've
gone through like a hedonist phase for
many years and i've explored all kinds
of stuff and i've come to the conclusion
that for me i want to be in a long-term
committed relationship and that's why
i'm getting married what you're made for
so i've tested all the waters right i've
seen all these things and i can't
imagine like the people's expectations
like are they warped like guys think
that they're going to be able to have a
lot of girls and have hookups or
whatever or women think they're going to
find their dream man like people's
expectations and the whole approach to
it need to be moderated which they're
not because
the guard rails
of the healthy community like you're
talking about have been totally stripped
away and people are just floundering
about sexual revolution all these things
i i so i pulled up the blog from okay
cupid and it's what you see
medium error 410 the author deleted this
medium story and what was the medium
story well there's an archive of it's
not too hard to find
as you can see from the gray line women
rate an incredible 80 percent of guys as
worse looking than medium very harsh on
the other hand when it comes to actual
messaging women shift their expectations
only just slightly ahead of the curve
which is a healthier pattern than guys
pursuing the all but unattainable but
with the basic rating so out of whack
the two curves together suggest some
strange possibilities for the female
thought process the most salient of
which is that the average looking woman
has convinced herself that the vast
majority of males aren't good enough for
her but she then goes right out and
messages them anyway well i'll say this
though i think because they're rating
men based on their appearance i think
women are much more likely to be with a
man who they don't see as being
inordinately physically attractive
because they like his personality i
think that's way more likely to happen
yeah or his status sure so even though
there's ability so yeah so even though
they're rating a lot of these guys is
below average i think a lot of them if
they knew them in real life thought they
had a good personality not all of them
i'm not up to lunch on this people are
selective but i think a lot more of
those people would get dates you're 100
sure sure but take a look there was a
there was another viral thing i saw on
reddit it was uh instagram model you
know real versus like uh reality versus
you know instagram
and they like even put fake abs on this
woman and that's horrible but so what
happens is uh instagram is making young
women extremely depressed yeah making
them hate their own bodies yeah but you
know what mark marky mark did the same
thing to me with his calvin klein ads
back in the 90s so this is going on a
long time did he photoshop himself
they're not real people like the the hip
to waist ratio is it possible in life
circumstances and when done right what
happens is it's not it's not affecting
guys the same way sure guys are going to
be like that's attractive and then it's
going to skew their perception but young
women look at that woman and then base
themselves off of something that doesn't
exist and now we're getting young women
getting plastic surgery to look like
instagram and snapchat filters totally
but the same thing happens chris
hemsworth he trains for nine months for
that one scene in avengers where his
shirt is off okay yes and then it's real
and they think it's real and then the
rest of the time he's you know not like
that and they dehydrate right right dude
they take drugs and they're on steroids
and they're on growth hormones that's
horrible they're starving about
hemsworth right not about fair enough
but models and even fitness models who
gear up for photo shoots to get the abs
and the whole thing that is like a
multi-month process i agree to get to
that stage it's not normal now we're at
the point where
you could at least recognize if i train
hard and then don't drink any water for
a day you'll be able to see all these
you know muscles there was a photo i
think it was of it might have been chris
hemsworth on the beach oh no no it was
uh jason moma is that his name yeah and
they were like looking thick what's
going on with that and it's like the
dude and then someone pointed out he's
still actively training for the movies
he's in he's just not dehydrating
himself he looks healthy no but on the
same tip though like guys there are ways
to raise your status it is a ruthless
game out there it's ruthless and you
have to raise your status but luckily
you can do it you can get fit you can
get strong you can raise your your your
intellect you can raise your financial
status you can dress better you you just
you have to you're competing globally
why do you look at me when you settle
i'm looking at the kids looking directly
looking through you could look much
better you could have a better job you
could comb your hair you could take a
shower you could wear pants
hey wait i'm taking this personally
no it's brutal i mean it's brutal out
there as that as a the latest uh
i was watching pop stars i was watching
well i think oh yeah oh heather and
brett weinstein we're talking about
evolutionary biology of male and female
gametes and like basically you can see
it in plants the male is not picky it
wants to give its
stamen or whatever to every plant out
there but the female plants are very
picky about what they receive because
they can only you know just receive one
here's the thing they're the gatekeepers
well yes but here's the thing that is
true but also when a man is picking
someone who he wants to marry we have
this culture where there's this
dichotomy right you're either looking
for someone um to have like a
meaningless sexual encounter with or
you're looking for someone for a more
serious long-term thing historically
like if a man was looking for a marriage
partner he was going to be more
selective than a lot of guys are when
they go out and sleep around indeed yeah
women are the gatekeepers to sex
men are the gatekeepers to relationships
right because the man decides to to give
up that urge of spreading the stamin
well and even even when it's not sex i
think you're right that at even when
it's not sex like if you're in a
community
with like churchgoers people are saving
themselves for marriage or don't have
sex there is still this element of the
woman being the gatekeeper for like the
initial interaction or the mutual
interest something like that and then
the guy is more the gatekeeper for
whether it
progresses down the path of being
something serious definitely i think we
are going to see a substantial
escalation in the transhumanist
movement and not in the
interesting sci-fi way right
transhumanist back in the day i remember
people talked about they're talking
about cybernetic implants sci-fi movies
integrating with neural link and virtual
reality and things like that which still
could be pretty questionable
but
now it's going to be identity crisis
which we're starting to see a lot of
for uh for a while there was like other
kin and i don't know if you guys know
about like the tumblr stuff where people
people would say like i was i'm they
would claim to be an owl trapped in a
human body or something like that i know
this girl who's like really really super
into tumblr
um and she was telling me i'm kidding
but um i i remember all of the memes
that used to float around about that
stuff and unfortunately some of it
seared into my mind and the other kin
were a really horrifying i was thinking
we were going to say i was just going to
say that i i have had a theory for a
while that the reason why we see
declining uh fertility rates in in
countries with advanced technology is
because that we are moving towards some
sort of evolutionary phase in which the
technology
is going to supplant the reproductive
elements yeah i think like a genderless
species that lives in deep space where
we get really long and then we clone and
just took it right to like the highest
level
like you know what i see a hundred years
in the future that's right jack is like
population is declining he's like jack
in space you won't be compressed by
gravity so you're going to be like
floating huge house have you ever seen
the expanse yeah that's where you got it
from right
the people who live in the asteroid belt
they're like tall and lanky because
they're there's less you know gravity
genderless too that's going to be
interesting if we i don't think that i
don't think we're going to become
generally senseless i just yeah no
people don't ian's wrong and and you're
technically right but what's good what
it's going to be is no no no no no
there's only one future no no no no hold
on it's because we're integrating with
machines right like did you guys not
listen to what alex jones had had been
he was screaming he was like they're
trying to integrate us into the machines
and they want to become immortal they
wanna they wanna get the robot implants
and things like that neural link
connecting your brain and your
consciousness into
cybernetics
so it's not going to be a hundred years
in the future we're gangly biological no
it's gonna be like you guys ever see
ghost in the shell
they put nanites in your brain and
cyberize and then connect you to the
network and then if your body is injured
you get a prosthetic body and then you
you get canceled on twitter they just
turn your brain off right and that's it
you're not just off twitter you're just
you just
have you guys in the black the black
mirror episode where someone
they get blocked in real life oh my gosh
and they just see the weird like
silhouettish kind of thing moving around
they're like you're blocked i can't hear
you you know what i mean
where i think oh i like that i don't
know i'll say this
jack's like sign me up i am so sick of
people i have blocked 11 000 people on
twitter and i'm not stopping i know a
lot of people are gonna instantly start
screaming alex jones is right you know
whatever so i don't know if he's right
about global elites wanting to turn
themselves into robots
but there have been just general you
know academics and scientists who have
talked about the gradual
integration with technology so for
example i'm wearing a smartwatch we all
have smartphones
we are cyborgs that's the way it's there
i was reading an article and it said
when when will humans fully integrate
cybernetics and they pointed out that
with cell phones we've actually
connected a part of our minds our
consciousness into a massive grid and we
use this connection device to maintain
communications it is it is the
preliminary stage oh my gosh uh google
incentivizes you to write content to do
research to put information out on the
internet so that you can get click so
that you get the dopamine it's directly
yes google search is directly connected
to your neurotransmitters in your brain
and when somebody else out there clicks
a button on your thing and you get and
it goes through space and all the way
into your brain it changes your brain
chemistry
as a i'm a twitter professional i i
don't feel bad saying that but i should
but i do
but i do know i do know that like
twitter is addictive yeah like
i can just feel myself scrolling
scrolling you know i get tens of
thousands of notifications every day so
she's like there's always just something
i read through all of them and i pull it
down boom there's another thousand i was
using i know i just got a wise phone
recently i'm gonna oh wow
soon yeah what's this so it's basically
it looks like a smartphone you know call
text and it has gps which is the reason
i got it instead of a flip phone but
it's literally just that calling texting
gps i waste so much time on my phone so
you couldn't just delete twitter no
because i know because then i'll go to
the website i'll find a way around it
dude i i once installed like when i was
writing my uh my book i installed on on
uh on my google chrome this like uh you
know time limiter like and i assigned
different websites to it and after you
used 15 minutes it blocked it yeah you
know and like there's no way to actually
unblock it unless you go through like a
series of like 50 questions but what
would i do at first that worked for like
a week
and then and then eventually i would
start downloading new browsers and then
i would start going through the
different like i've just found a way to
get around the roblox i had set up for
myself so a phone that doesn't have the
capability or the ability to download
those apps that sounds like it might be
is that the is that that's not the wise
phone no that's not the wise phone so
when i installed it i was having some
trouble because i formally had an iphone
and so people who spoke to me on
imessage even after i turned imessage
off i wasn't getting their messages on
the other phone and i have clients who
communicate with me that way so i needed
to put it back here until i can figure
out how to make it work but i wanna i
wanna ask all of you guys a question
because i know jack jack's answer
compared to ian's answer is going to be
complete other ends of the spectrum and
then sheamus will make a joke graphene
the question is probably dmt humans
gradually integrating with machines and
a future where human consciousness
exists in
machines expanding and drifting about
space good or bad
inevitable bad
bad i'm going to let them answer for but
bad no i'll start with you no sir
because first of all you will and i'm
sorry i know people are going to
disagree with me on this this might
spark an entire debate but you will
never have a human being's conscious
mind sitting on a circuit board what's
going to happen is they're going to
attempt to deconstruct a person's mind
and have a computer simulate that but
you cannot literally move your
consciousness out of your brain and into
a
computer going to watch a video those
will be computers emulating human
behavior to some extent but you will be
dead you ever watched star trek yes you
know they have the transport you know
they have the transport kills you and
remakes you yeah would you ever use one
if it so if it just killed you in your
major no how would you know yeah exactly
so it's it my understanding is that it's
actually true in star trek
you
you die and then they recreate you
and so it's just other people see you as
this like approximation this identical
structure but you actually die in the
transport apparatus that's disputed
though because so
here's the thing they started trying to
ask me he asked me if i watched star
trek because there are episodes and i
think there's one episode in particular
where you see someone's pov when they
get transported and they get transport
you see them getting transported to one
place and it fails and they go back to
the other which means they were
conscious through the whole thing
actually they weren't they didn't
recreate it except riker got cloned by a
male function in the process so yeah no
you're right it is uh so so what's the
whole with the show no you're right it's
a plot hole with the show but yeah this
is a famous thought experiment um
if you were teleported by having your
entire body deconstructed and then
reconstructed somewhere else i would
assume it would kill you and recreate
you but then we come we have a question
we've never seen something like this
occur so maybe when the body gets
recreated there's just nothing animating
it your soul has left your body and you
just have a dead body that's identical
to yours in another place would that not
be really crazy if like we we develop
transportation like matter
transportation technology and every time
a person goes through it they just
reappear and then slump over dead yeah
they're buying those things like yeah
the soul is gone
so back to my original question good or
bad uh
i think bad uh i think it's bad because
i'm trying to envision
a a consciousness of myself
that isn't
immediately drawn towards the ocean that
isn't immediately drawn towards nature
that doesn't immediately receive
positive reinforcement from actual
tactile contact with nature actual
contact with the ocean with the sunshine
and and what that does for me as just as
my soul like what does that do for me
it's it is
essential to my well-being i can't
imagine those things being reproduced in
a way where you're living on a circuit
board in which the sunshine
actually the transmission of the
sunlight into your body or the the the
alignment that you feel with the earth
when you when you get in sync with the
waves or that you spend time out in
nature deeply simulated bro in the
matrix you know i just i get there's got
to be at some point and we see it now we
still see it so maybe technology gets
better but but there's still a
difference between analog and digital
there's still a difference what do you
think ian um i i think that the the
chemicals that we'll use to build these
circuit boards where our brains will
will be emulated is natural like silicon
lithium it's stuff it's all natural
processes from the earth that we're
reformatting we call it synthetic but
it's still natural stuff that we've
synthesized and it's inevitable and if
we don't do it those that do will
enslave and destroy the rest of us but
you're assuming that we know enough
about consciousness to recreate it and
you're assuming that circuit boards we
assemble well that's true right but
the argument that's made is
consciousness is just information
processing at the level of the brain and
so if we get a computer to process
information the right way then it's
going to be conscious i don't buy that
at all there's more to consciousness
than that we have a soul and i know a
lot of people like
track
yes
have you ever seen the make of a man
also i think it's called the man when
data is on trial effectively determine
whether or not he's a sentient
independent life form yeah yeah
these are these are tough questions man
well in science fiction we see this a
lot i just i genuinely i don't believe
that we are ever going to create a
circuit board that there is something
that it is like to be
and also even if we could do that which
we can't but even if we could and we're
able to
the idea that you could transfer your
mind from your brain
or in body into that other thing rather
than just having something new being
created or a computer simulating you um
is also impossible
i want to see this guy play detroit
become human
who i want to see you play detroit
become human you ever play the game no
it's like there's a bunch of robots that
are for like they look like people and
they're used for menial tasks and then
they become sentient and then they
demand freedom and there's like you know
analogs to like slavery and stuff
westworld
yeah yeah yeah but i imagine sheamus
would play it like destroy all the
robots they're not exactly they're not
thinking they don't feelings they don't
have feelings well this is the other
question too
because i don't believe that you would
be the first to die in westworld well
and exactly because because once they do
create these machines that are clearly
not conscious but people believe his
conscience just because they seem to be
simulating um
thought
i'm gonna be a bigot right because i'm
gonna say no i'm going to be saying no
there's no lights on in there and
they're going to go equal rights for
robots and so then we're going to move
resources that should be going to human
while being in comfort to making us feel
like these circuit boards are happy even
though that's a completely absurd
concept i feel like the high status
thing in the future will be to be as
natural and human as possible ooh i feel
like the plibs
the plebes the plebs are going to be the
ones that get all circuited up and like
turned into work machines and whatever
and like if you can preserve your actual
bio body that to me seems like it would
be the highest status
maybe i think that's interesting i have
to agree with you i think the plebs will
be like
oh you want this job well you need the
eye modification otherwise you can't
work yeah yeah exactly the rich people
won't have to undergo any kind of
special but you need to take this
vaccine but they're gonna they're gonna
have they're gonna have fibrous
modification like stronger muscles
better bones
so but not the brain it's not the brain
i mean i'm already a cyborg i have i
have seven pins and a plate in my arm
i've got you're not conscious i've got
another humans oh i'm just about ready
to talk about it
i had surgery i had chest surgery i tore
my pec telling the world it came out
uh
someone else's tendon implanted inside
of me and drywall screws and hangers
drilled into my bones and stuff like
like you know it it's it's happening in
that regard but your brain your essence
your soul
you know the last time i was on the show
i'm taking a huge u-turn here last time
i was on this show i said ged a bunch jc
a bunch and a few other things and you
crossed yourself every time i said have
you noticed yes i appreciate that thank
you but i appreciate it but that wasn't
for you that just is yeah i appreciate
it i've had quite an evolve i've had
quite an evolution since the last time
uh we've talked and so i'm trying to
think like this god you know spirit in
me how is it going to be recreated on a
computer board well it'll be like a
mycelial uh creation that's like
semi-synthetic it'll be like a carbon
you know silicon
organism that you're remote viewing
through probably
well and this is what gets really
interesting right because
i think we can imagine a scenario where
somebody who is mentally disabled could
have some kind of computer enhancement
placed into their brain so they can
operate at a normal level and then the
question becomes at what point have you
destroyed the brain to the point where
the person is dead and now it's just
circuit boards simulating that person's
behavior
um
and that's a question now i believe
if you got to that point the person
would probably just be visibly dead but
if we develop
biotechnical enhancements that are
capable of emulating human behavior like
we've discussed at what point would you
know if it was still the person who was
alive or the robot that took over right
there
and what if the robot is a singular
entity and we assume it to be individual
like we see a person it's it's jack he's
acting like jack what we don't realize
is that it's actually connected to a
major grid of one singular computational
force through the network and then at
some point it unifies and then every
single person with these implants turns
and says we must prevent human expansion
and all of them act the exact same way
if sam harris wasn't so impossible it
would be interesting to have a
conversation with him about this but i
was thinking about my dog and i and i
say this about my dog all the time i
love my dog she loves me i look at her
though and i say to to my fiance my wife
to me i say you know the dog she's just
she's just a machine she's like a shark
she's just an algorithm she's an
algorithm of behaviors that she's
learned in order like if she does this
she gets loved she does this and we
appreciate it she does that she gets
food she does she try trial and error
trial and error and it it gives you the
illusion of love
yeah but and i don't know it's
affectionate i agree dogs cannot love
because they cannot make they cannot
will they do not have an intellect
it's just an emotional casket like i
love i love the dog i love the dog i
know i am like chemically bonded to the
dog i can feel it right i smell her and
i feel it it's chemically bonded to you
too but chemical a chemical bond isn't
love how do you know the dog doesn't
have
well because i've seen the way the dog
is with other people
what does that mean well like i mean
they the lo they can apply the love to
whomever right it's so could you suck at
a person i know i just feel like
complex social behavior does not
determine whether or not somebody has a
soul
right that's that's
that's exactly what i'm saying i'm
saying the dog exhibits complex mental
and emotional behavior but does the dog
have a soul sure is the dog anything
more than an agglomeration of like of an
algorithm of like just trial and error
like computer people so i think it's
magnetic field is part of its soul well
i think both things can be true so um
humans and animals and this is what we
believe as catholics is that humans and
animals both have souls but different
kinds of souls and so
the human has an eternal soul and a
rational soul we're capable of making
decisions we have an intellect we have
free will animals have a soul animating
them
but they don't have the ability to make
decisions the way we do they can't think
through things the way we can and so
they can't love because love is a
decision it's in animals don't have free
will they only operate based on their
biological impulses whereas humans have
more than instinct i don't think
chickens have souls i believe they do i
don't believe that they have eternal
souls i don't believe they have rational
souls but i believe they're animated
i look at how chickens act and i'm like
you know when you say their algorithms
and programs dogs i don't see as doing
that dogs can have really unique
personalities and behave in ways that
you're surprised by and they can learn
but man chickens are just like
i feel like i'm playing a video game
where you just mass produce these
generic things that just function that
that's how i feel
super impressed
so i i get what you're really dumb
they they it's it's
well you want them to be dumb enough to
stay in their cage all day and just eat
the food and poop out their eggs for you
and i agree that that chickens are
right there but i believe
even though chickens are stupid that
there is an experience that a chicken
has like there is something it is like
to be a chicken i think a chicken feels
things i think it's not smart it doesn't
know much it's very limited
but
i do believe a chicken feels like i
don't believe it as a soul
is memory what humans have is memory and
i was down and i realized it comes from
the word me m-e me when we as a species
realize that there is a me that i am me
i am different than you i am and the
word new n-o-o-s dogs
dogs have the same they have they have
the uh it's a psychological concept
where they can understand that there's
things outside of them self-awareness
and they can also understand object
permanence they can also understand that
just because the thing isn't there it
still exists yeah they're developing
memory there are certain animals that do
it's hard to they've done experiment
it's because it's difficult to know how
you could ever possibly know this right
but they've done experiments where
they've been able to theorize based on
the results that certain very
intelligent animals
seem to know that they are different
from their environment which seems to be
what you're saying yeah me what about
the starter test i don't know that like
a dog wouldn't go who am i yeah the
mirror test is what i'm talking about
yeah but the animals and sitting there
like like who am i what are my thoughts
i'm thinking this but they can they can
sort of understand intuitively it seems
based on these experiments that they are
a different thing from their environment
there are some animals that have only a
few i don't remember which ones that
passed the mirror test where they'll put
like a sticker on the forehead and then
put them in front of a mirror and then
the animal look and then you know some
you know if it's a chimp or an ape or
something they'll just take it off and
be like recognizing themselves in a
reference exactly yeah yeah birds think
the reflection is another bird
and even some dogs do and they like
they'll get angry and stuff mm-hmm it's
really funny putting the chickens in
front of mirrors and they're just like
freaking out yeah it was funny i got the
head movement down oh yeah you've been
practicing but i've been hanging out
with the chickens too much
you know our dog realized because i
think i remember when we were kids we
had this big mirror in our front room
and my brother was in the other room
where the dog could only see him through
a mirror and he held the treat up and
the dog like
bolted out sideways and like he knew
that it was a reflection yeah so here's
the thing though we we've selected uh
dogs you know we we've artificially
selected dogs for reasons true dogs
understand pointing do you guys know
this yeah and chimps don't are close
some of the closest uh the most similar
animals to us dude never ever you ever
try and point at something for a cat
what does a cat do it looks at your
finger right yeah look just ghost your
finger and sniff it a dog will
understand when you point he'll look in
the direction of what you're pointing
that's incredible because dogs point
themselves actually with their nose they
well a dog a dog can identify where
something is and the dog will point at
it you know why you know why you can see
the whites of a dog's eyes but not cats
tell me timmy dogs are are descended
from pack animals and so
the other wolves being able to see the
direction the the other wolf was looking
allowed them to make quicker decisions
cats are independent so they don't they
don't need so the dogs with the lighter
eyes probably became natural leaders
because the other ones could follow them
easier you can when you look at a dog
you can see the dog move his eyes around
and know where he's looking cats their
eyes are huge and they just will move
their heads around and you know so this
makes me think about becoming a cyborg
having memory like what is what are we
other than our memory of what we are oh
that's a good question i mean we're a
body soul composite because even if you
damaged your memory you're absolutely
right that something about you would
change but it would still be you but not
to me
but i don't know
you are not just what you are to you
either
no
where uh um brendan frazier goes in a
coma and then goes to like some weird
claymation universe and then a cartoon
character he created takes over his
consciousness no
i'll come on fine
tim what are you doing so much time on
netflix
i watched this back when i was a kid in
the 90s come on brendan frazier vhs he's
amazing
all the time it was amazing we had a
7-eleven next to our blockbuster so i
remember being a little kid and then i'd
come across five bucks somehow and i'd
be like oh you would steal five dollars
don't try it did you guys ever you know
road runner video or is that an ohio
thing
what about oh yeah what about video 66
off route 66 i think that was maybe just
i don't i don't know if we had road
runner you know where where i was we had
hollywood and blockbuster hollywood
hollywood video oh
yeah they had blockbusters open until
like i was almost done with high school
it's crazy how long they limped along
there so in the future there's a bunch
of different ways things can go
i feel like
the long
so i was i was reading about predictions
of the future from academics and and
sci-fi novelists and and physicists and
they said things like
you know the ultimate end of humanity is
we create machines that ultimately
replace us we're completely gone from
the equation
and the universe
has been expanding rapidly and then you
have complex machines just adrift doing
literally nothing
until they come across some free energy
to absorb and then replicate then create
another
object it might it might start with
humans being like i want better eyes i
want to run faster but over time
eventually the human experience is
removed as being a liability or being
unnecessary and then eventually
you're the borg but even even the borg
still had biological faith exactly like
we're talking about putting you in a
computer again i don't care
how much you overclock the processor you
are not going to run a human soul on
that thing and
a lot of people would like to and it's
just wishful thinking well if i don't
honestly i think i think a lot of it is
they believe that at the end of life
that's just it they won't go on or some
of them on some level know that they
don't want to be judged by god at the
end of their life and so it's i have to
get my i need to find some way to just
extend it as far as possible instead of
thinking how to how they can live a good
life now i would be interested to see of
the scientists who believe it would be
possible to get enough circuits together
to recreate the human brain how many of
them are atheists probably most because
you would have to have a completely
naturalistic
interpretation of consciousness
right i can't imagine believing in a
soul and thinking that it could be
placed under a microphone right because
if you believe in a soul if you believe
in creation you believe in god you you
believe that you're not god exactly how
are you going to actually make that
happen well you'll make a carbon-based
life form and send it out so like spores
like if i'm gonna if i'm gonna see the
universe with life i would do it with
carbon i found out graphene's awesome i
love carbon
little spores that can exist in deep
space and just send them out everywhere
and they'd eventually hit planets with
oceans and then start to generally grow
into this thing that has a soul
apparently because we seem to have come
from spores on some level
um i wonder how much ian just makes it
also i was going to say spores can live
in deep space we started with ian first
realizing that politicians might not be
honest with us you know how he's like
he's like i know how we could create an
entire civilization with souls and
spores a mushroom
is light on one side and dark on the
bottom you've noticed that about
mushrooms no when in in space they
orient the light side aims towards a
star towards light and then starts to
spin and that spinning creates
generation of motion and that's what it
starts with mushrooms yeah spores
mushrooms like fungus fungal species so
you think fungal spores are moving
through space yeah and they they can
live in deep space and that's apparently
panspermia is the idea that spores
landed in earth's oceans and then grew
over time into animal life and so you
guys got to see the cass castle vlog
it's it's so we had alex jones over he
came on the show and then as part of the
vlog we do animations we have cantu is
an animator and then it's not the next
one after jones but the next one after
that i can't remember which title it is
but it's um the wolf spider ian it's the
wolf spider episode ian finds a mushroom
it's an animation of like you gotta
watch it it's alex jones and ian on a
magical mushroom adventure and i was
just like
it's amazing he took audio from the show
and then made this ridiculous story of
ian and alex jones and it's just really
good it's hilarious mushrooms are
underrated
outer space flying mushrooms i think
that the what happened was that the
fungus landed in the ocean and then some
of it started to eat plant matter and
that stuff turned into fungus and then
the ones that ate other fungus became
animals
i'm gonna wear it on the sleeve i'm
gonna wear it on the sleeve i don't
believe that but i am curious
i'm curious like why why is it mushrooms
that you believe seeded the earth
wildlife there's no no he said that the
mushrooms got here and then ate the
existing plant material that's what he
just said oh so then there already was
okay i'm sorry i'm sorry i misunderstood
i misunderstood that yeah so there was
already life here
at some point it seems like something
might have landed on earth that wasn't
here originally yeah why is that there's
actually uh there have been some
hypotheses that fungus did not
come to existence the same way other
life on the planet did and may have come
from space
but also you look at the way the moon
smashed through earth like at the planet
thea um
a hypothesis is where there's like 26
planetoid bodies in the early solar
system smashing into each other and
that's why you have this asteroid belt
of collision and at one point this
planetoid smashed into earth it was in
its orbit and they came out the other
side this ball of magma cooled into what
we know as the moon so it's like a
unique setup what we got so here's the
i'm still very fascinated by this this
idea of fungus potentially having come
from outer space what's so i mean is it
not composed of dna and the same genetic
building blocks that everything on earth
is composed of what's fundamentally
different about fungus that would
necessitate we believe it came from
space now now we need to get uh what's
his name the my psychologist i read some
articles oh yeah okay like i i think
paul's standards i'm not gonna pretend
like it's true or anything like that
okay i was reading some scientific
journal and they were like you know
people have speculated no i've heard
that people have speculated that
mushrooms are what spurred uh the
intellectual and emotional evolution of
primates into human beings through
creative energy and it came from other
spaces other places don't know if i buy
that either in fact the more i learn
about all of this i'm sort of starting
to buy the one big theory the one the
big guy theory like i'm getting there
i'm glad i gotta hear it yeah i am yeah
i mean it
it makes as much sense as anything else
i've heard in this room actually a
little bit a lot more i hope i mean
that's the meanest thing you've ever
said about my
religion me your time i'm giving you i'm
giving you
bobby there's like a god field that's
like vibrating things to
form creation
uh
i don't know that could be happening
alongside fungus landing on earth i
would imagine maybe it's all happening
together yeah
how about we go to super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.com sign
up for that members only exclusive
content coming up later tonight and uh
putting your super chats now because
we're gonna start reading a bunch of
them and again smash like button no name
says i believe in vaccines but not
getting covet jab because the government
tells me to ian and alex jones need a
spin-off show
oh my goodness that's what we were
saying the other day like one of the
things i want to do is like next time
alex is in town just turn the camera on
and leave just ian and alex to talk for
as long as they want to i imagine it
might create some kind of like power
nexus vortex of crazy energies and then
like you know all of a sudden the house
gets sucked into a singularity and we're
just like
i don't know what they said yeah but
they'll uncover the secrets of the
universe i'm sure it's a it's a
conversation that should have happened
in 2009 so the potential energy has
increased so much that it's like the
strong nuclear force at work but once
they fuse then it's just chill
michael fernando mello says great show
guys red flags cnn bloomberg cdc
director gun violence is a serious
public health threat npr today cdc
funding gun violence violence research
again remember how they handled covid
well also did you know that when the cdc
researched this in the past they found
that guns are more often used
defensively than they are for crimes
that's right significantly more often
it's so funny when we have pre-show
conversations about the same exact thing
and sheamus says
we'll talk about all the gun stuff in
the member segment that's going to be
fun um and i'll talk about some of the
uh items i've procured recently
the
wiry says i out loud yelled the illinois
boys
we need merch we need illinois boys
merch we do get on we got to get this
together we should do an illinois boys
shirt is there any way we can get the
rights to the boys or back in town no
the beginning of each show
that's that's that thing that's i think
that's thin lizzy what if we just do a
cover can we get the rice to do a cover
if we play the illinois words
we can do um the illinois boys are back
in the city by thick lonnie let's do it
mm-hmm
yes exactly a silhouette of that of jack
a couple melodies and a shirt and you
and the illinois boys ever see you ever
see that 30 rock episode where they want
to do the janice joplin biopic but they
don't have the right so they call it
jorm or something
it was so funny that's pretty funny yeah
there should be an anime short of us
illinois boys coming up soon hey maybe
fighting guns maybe maybe we could do a
maybe we could do a cartoon about uh
about that maybe free mayor we're free
to start talking about the illinois boys
at some point you know
would people understand that
of course every everyone knows who the
illinois boys are tim
we took the nation by storm world famous
dude
what do we do
are we singers are we a boy
basketball we are the legendary
podcasting trio exactly yeah the
illinois boys
tim
i'm disappointed like a group of actors
that you've forgotten who you are we're
a troop
a troop of cybernetics forgotten who he
is uh and it breaks the man's heart to
hear him sell out all right purposeful
porpoise says
tim the sg jamie jim comp
yeah
jim was it jamie
it was it was
jenny george
purposeful porpoise says tim the sg-1
episode where general hammond admits
aliens is called wormhole extreme is
that one or two episodes after that he
looks into the camera only time ever in
the series yup that was really funny i
don't think there's an existing actual
stargate portal though
would be nice
would be nice it's actually a scary
concept in the show stargate that there
is um
beneath this mountain a portal that
links to this network of all these other
planets and alien technology and no one
knows no one on earth knows and they let
people through without vaccines or
anything like that and that's the worst
part yeah no that's actually a big plug
no that's actually a big part of the
show they go to planets and then people
die they go like hey anyone could just
come in you know they go to one planet
where there's like this alien humanoid
species and they all start just dying
because you know and so they actually
have quarantine measures they they talk
about in the show and stuff like that
that's interesting
all right let's see we got
james dorping house says illinois boys
together again it's always a good time
with jack and sheamus love the show as
always keep it the good work thank you
sir
there better be all right waiting for us
that's right jimmy mack and jack
geodetti says we need a jack brunch in
stroudsburg pa stroudsburg pa uh i'll
we'll look at that for round two guys
round two closest one will be washington
dc on february 27th uh i'm doing the tim
brenner uh we're gonna do
done we're gonna have the shame
breakfast
you guys can all feel free well i'm
gonna pick the exact same towns as jack
across the street
no that would actually just be cool to
have more people show up indeed it works
february 27th just have illinois boys
meals the three square meals a day with
the illinois that's what we're gonna do
it's just like portillo's giordano's and
like maxwell street
all right cigars and sig arms says the
only benefit of a republican-run senate
is a delay to the inevitable breakup the
inevitable breakup breakup of the union
why not just hurry up and get the pain
over with while we're still young you
know i'm i'm going to go ahead and just
say i'd defer to sarah silverman because
she always is yeah she's just the beacon
of political insight of course that we
look for in dark times like this and
she's called for it so don't look at me
you know i keep thinking about this one
of the reasons that we wanted to have a
large republic that was united under one
system was because if we had a bunch of
smaller states within this one continent
it'll just be a matter of time before
we're just killing each other and
shredding each other up into tiny little
bits which we did at one point we did do
that we did do that so anybody that is
like looking forward to some sort of
balkanization do you remember what
happened in the balkans but yeah but
here's the other don't i think the fear
is that the federal government because
also look what's happened with a lot of
very large democratic nations in the
past where the government just starts
killing their own people so i think the
fear is if we don't balkanize that's
going to happen so what happened in the
balkans well you're going to end up with
the state of pennsylvania killing all
the remaining virginians in the state
they're like you're you're a virginian
you gotta die and they'll be like
virginian genocide in the state of
pennsylvania and then there'll be like
border attacks and there'll be like
resource competition and poor access and
there's a reason why we have a big
country it's to keep us all from killing
each other
i think but you see i think you can
achieve that without us all being
governed under this unbelievably
gigantic monolithic government that can
tell everyone to do whatever they want
to tell us to do at any time there's
just there's problems can we again
no i i acknowledge that there would be
problems but then it's the question are
those problems would the problems with
the national divorce truly be greater i
think everyone in this country should
get together and secede sheamus from the
union yeah hold on we can have a big
party without them
to illinois with the boys and then we're
not even a troop anymore oh jimmy think
about yourself
billy billy warren says tim you've said
the republic is no more well obama said
as a joke in his final correspondence
the end of the republic never looked so
good everyone laughed not knowing he was
serious yikes
make 1984 fiction again says the omnibus
spending bill last year was 1500 pages
and was just and was distributed to
congress four hours before they had to
vote on it all you need to know speed
reasons how did we how did we pass this
last this long
yeah that's that's horrible i thought it
was 5 000 pages
does it matter if it's more than 60
pages ain't nobody reading it it's true
they're just thumbing through to find
their section for their pork they're
like oh did we get that did we get that
grant for our oh we did
yeah but with the level of intellect the
people running our country have to vote
on this stuff they should have to give
them like pop-up books man it should be
like maybe like 50 words you have if you
can't explain it that quickly right then
they just don't get to vote on it right
right i heard a funny joke about that
sorry one last thing about the people
that are running our country that the
guy who is in the the congressman the
house representative from your district
is only the second most successful used
car salesman in your town because the
first most successful one is still there
selling cars
caleb welch says you are here with alex
jones tonight has already been removed
from youtube elijah and sydney put here
setting new records out here sending
records hunter fuses i was listening to
you are here live when the feed suddenly
cut on me big tech be on their bs all
because they had alex jones as a guest
oh that's interesting geeks oh hey i got
uh 5 593 pages in that omnibus
ted two says
mark levin on the show to discuss his
new book american marxism and what
people can do to push back it'll leave
you speechless
it's a good copy
more people pointing out nick says big
brother just killed the live feed for
you are here
wow man
alien space bone says tim would 10 years
ago you ever think we would end up
you you would end up an m82 toten
country living chicken whisperer keeping
the fantastic work i really enjoy
watching the growth and evolution of
what you do yes i it was absolutely a
possibility um i've never been like
opposed to guns my position was always
just like fairly moderate like well i
think there are some things we can do to
have you know common sense and so i was
like people want to have an m82 by all
means you just you know we got to talk
about mental illness and things like
that now i'm just like
it's a constitution you can't change it
like you can't you can't overrule it you
can change it through a convention of
states or an actual process but if you
want to change that you got to go
through the process you can't just
mandate you can't just
legislate past what the law of the land
says so
but yeah definitely i'll tell you this
if i came to you guys 10 years ago and
said
in 10 years
donald trump will have been president
and on the way out there would have been
1 000 people like breaking into the
capitol building shutting it all down
you know there would be a pandemic
they'd shut everything down people would
be getting you know the government would
be forcing them all to get vaccinated in
in australia there'd be camps everywhere
where if you want to come in there they
they take you and they put you there and
then people are sitting there you can't
take your mask off people are getting
arrested in the streets there's riots
people
probably wouldn't have believed it it
reminds me of that scene from back to
the future where he's explaining to uh
the
kooky professor he's like ron reaga's
president he goes ronald reagan the
actor
so you know who's the president ronald
reagan
yep
all right
let's see
that fell flat it was documented i don't
like when you install ronald reagan jack
i told you that you know it really hurts
my face
it's donna ghee
mo row says in the last year of my phd
in biomedical nanotechnology 90 000 and
10 years of my life to science and now
i'm out because i won't bend the knee to
authoritarians wow stay strong and stay
faithful folks good for you much respect
yes
the right intel with curtis j says the
naiveness of ian is not funny guys it's
literally the cause of our downfall yeah
better people on your panel no i
completely disagree i think ian
expressing the stuff that we can then
respond to allows a lot of people who
don't understand what's going on to
understand so this is this is what i
talk to people about what i don't want
to do is have
often i think i think we have we're a
bit niche and esoteric in many
capacities but we definitely need people
like you know ian to ask questions that
most people are asking when they're
watching shows like this you gotta
understand this is a character i'm
playing a function on tim cast irl right
now so that this does not become an echo
chamber i mean this is who he is off
camera just like watch watch ted danson
talk about his role on curb your
enthusiasm he's playing a function to
allow larry to be crazier like i'm here
to make sure that we don't create an
echo chamber it's not just that it's
like if you know when we talked about
data and star trek i immediately thought
a lot of people are like i have no idea
what that means
what's data you know so we need someone
to say i don't know who data is and he
didn't i know you're fired man who's
data no i know who data is no exactly
you want i'm going to be vocally
ignorant so that we can
solve problems and
please put inspirational music behind
that like i will be vocally ignorant
yeah man i think people need to to let
go of their of their fear of being
humiliated and
and ask questions you don't know the
answers to and
and live with this i will say people are
watching a show like no let me stress
this point
a lot of people who watch who are like
making these comments about ian are the
people who know what's going on and
they're like i don't need to hear this
question ian's being not even asking
this why am i because the average person
who's watching might be like i have no
idea what that means and then ian asks
it and they go oh
so it's hard for us to just
we assume we but we assume people know
what we know so we have to have a
different group of voices so that we try
and have a broader conversation i think
that's one of the reasons the show works
for a lot of regular people who are like
i had never heard of that and i know it
was and then you explained it to ian and
now i get it otherwise we gloss over it
we talk about some complex political
issue and then we look at each other and
we wink like afghanistan am i right and
then we high five and then someone
watching the show was like what does
that mean yeah you know what's that all
about what's afghanistan i appreciate
the foil the uh the counterbalance he's
always disagreeing
yeah
you got that one you're a genius
thank
tom024 says carbon credit lockdowns are
coming next mastercard already rolled
out a carbon credit tracker unreal
search mastercard carbon calculator it's
up on their site now driving taxes we
didn't even get into that eight cents
you know you know what can i have 16
bucks that's how much it cost me to get
up here is that that's like passed you
know doesn't buy your electric car no
it's it's in the bill it's in the bill
all right our electric vehicles uh
omitted and this is i'm
not sure i think the purpose of it i
don't know if it's a carbon tax i think
it's a road use tax yeah because if it
was just supposed to be a carbon tax you
could argue well then they could just
increase the amount that they place on
gasoline because then that's going to
tax people who use more gasoline more
rather than i mean this is a really
terrible thing yes it is because i was
reading even forbes was saying this is
not from like some conspiracy theory
website but to implement this you would
have to put a gps tracker in everybody's
car to know where they're driving all
the time and how far they've got
definitely not definitely first of all
first of all there's computers in all of
your cars already you go and get your
inspection they just plug the cord into
the computer the computer on the car
tells the computer there all the
information about your car that could
easily transmit your mileage it gets
recorded every time you register your
car it gets recorded with your insurance
that part will be easy by the way you
also carry a phone around with you
everywhere you go that tracks where you
are but i can't believe i can leave that
phone at home you can but tracking it is
not going to be that difficult i think
the main issue is that if you make forty
thousand dollars a year and you drive
twenty thousand miles a year that's
sixteen hundred dollars that you're
getting which is straight up four
percent of your income which means you
have to work almost 10 days a year just
to pay this new tax i agree that that is
also i agree that that's also horrible
but it's still extremely invasive yeah
that's yeah i agree that's insane like
but even forbes saying like oh they'd
have to put a gps tracking car i mean
that's just unbelievably invasive and
horrifying but i agree with you that
that's that is outrageous yeah you know
do you know that most uh most cars for a
long time have had self-driving
capabilities let me let me explain that
i don't mean they can literally press a
button to drive itself i mean for the
past decade you could remote control a
car the car didn't require a human being
sitting in the seat for it to move and
turn and drive the steering's always
been has been mechanized for a long time
so when the car hackers back in the
early 2010s we're like look what we can
do type in a keyboard and the car drives
and just goes
yeah cars could be remote controlled for
a very long time now all they're doing
is putting cameras in those cars so they
can calculate distance to objects
i uh i have like a i have a 2012 13 ford
explorer it's a nice car i've been
taking care of it i rented a car the
other day i'm driving and and i had no
idea that had technology in it i'm
driving and i'm like i'm like why am i
why am i wrestling with this damn car
like i'm going over to the lane and it's
jerking me around i'm like no i'm like
i'm thinking there was something wrong
with the car something wrong with the
road and i finally figured out like
after a day of like fighting like
literally fighting with the car that it
was keeping me in the middle of the lane
i had no idea wow what yeah i had no
idea i'm like fighting with modern cars
a lot of them do this yeah i'm trying
because you know i like to change lane
sometimes i don't always use the signal
and if you don't put the signal on
you start to cross over the line without
using your signal and it will jerk you
back into the middle so i'm thinking i'm
like having this wrestling match with
the car on the highway and then i
learned oh you have to put the signal on
we got we got an important one here vosh
says hey speaking of finances seamus did
you ever pay knowles that 50 bucks you
promised him uh that's really more of a
personal
question i don't i just don't think that
that like
you can be honest so the thing about um
money is if you guys want to support the
show you can go to patreon.com
freedomtunes
and it maybe would help but michael
knowles and i have
a wrestling match coming up
we have we've reached an
understanding
i understand that he's going to keep
emailing me and he understands i'm not
going to pay him
i have no idea what you're talking about
all right dozerman says tim please play
or read the last part of eisenhower's
speech he mentions the medical and
technological elite setting public
policy
i'm just you know i'm really fed up with
these luddites resisting the technocracy
yeah of course who did mark zuckerberg
is
amazing
brilliant just look into his eyes he's
so warm and loving he's taking care of
you he's obviously a caretaker look you
just you guys
can't be a lot you just go on facebook
you don't even have to think it's just
all there for you you go on twitter they
tell you on the right side of the screen
what's true and what's not you don't
even got to think about it
well it's true i mean i love that they
have gotten everything right throughout
the entire pandemic and all the things
that they said were conspiracy theories
that we shouldn't talk about turned out
to be conspiracy theories we shouldn't
talk about no one's taking those things
uh seriously at this point so i love
that they got everything right and it
makes a lot of sense that they're
doubling down right now on censoring
people because they've been nothing but
correct the entire time and the people
disagreeing with them have not been
validated once i need my electrolyte
drink oh yeah plants like electrolytes
need yeah we have this fancy uh eternal
right you know i'll tell you why i'm
going full bore with this metaverse
project is because i do think that the
technocracy is coming and so i want to
build it first
it's a free software and open source
software so that we have control over it
or some sense of liberty when we use it
otherwise it's going to be created
privately and dangerous
what the culture war is
is the federation versus the borg
you have
varying cultures and ideas and
ideologies and debates and conversations
versus one unified cult ideology that is
plugged into their network that believe
everything that's sent to them so they
are not the borg in the sense that
they're fully plugged in mechanized but
this phone
keeps these these people from escaping
their paranoid delusional state
even when they're wrong and obviously
wrong and insanely wrong they still
watch rachel maddow they still go to
their phone and say just tell me what to
think oh that changed i don't care i'll
do whatever you say
they are networked
like the board there's a large portion
of them
so if you gave a borg some psilocybin
they would snap out of it is this like
give a mouse a cookie yeah give a borg
some psilocybin i don't know what
happened i have no way you know i don't
even know that's how you do it yeah
that's how you beat the board
give them i don't know i think it's the
opposite i think they have the board
up and that's what vanessa stoller says
on the dating
matt christiansen's media website has a
dating app for his and blonde's
listeners there have been many marriages
found through that link based on similar
interests people emailed me apparently
they were saying like you should make a
tim cass dating app so that listeners of
the show can like connect with each
other and i'm like that's a little too
far for me you know what i mean like
maybe the metaverse you'll have like
what a dating function in it yeah where
you can find people or you don't need a
dating app you just message someone you
don't want to be love doctor tim here's
what you do sheamus you go in the
comments of any tim cast article and you
say i'm a single 34 year old male and
i'm looking for a long walk on the beach
and then those those those fly honeys
will respond
true it's actually true
you want to get girls timkes.com that's
right that's it become a member at
timcast.com we should make a commercial
where it's like a guy he signs up and
then also a bunch of beautiful women
come into his room and he's like yeah
and they're all like dancing like beer
commercials here's what we need to do
you need to start a dating platform on
the website and then we need to start a
podcast called love doctor sheamus where
people call in when they are having
problems with their relationships like
usually you can like subscribe
you call tech support if you have a
problem with the website but if you're
having a problem with the relationship
you formed on the website you call
sheamus for relationship support you
know i love doctor i am not tells you
what you're doing right like you need to
listen more you need to let's do it
let's do it i'm so down oh my goodness
i'm not kidding let's do it love dr
coughlin
love dr jimmy mack dr mack
that's it it all comes together and then
we'll have to have like at the beginning
of every episode
james cochran is not a doctor she is not
a doctor he's absolutely not qualified
to be giving the advice he's giving
please don't listen to anything he says
but dubai fear discretion it's advised
i'm taking a sauna tonight oh yeah
i've decided
all right let's uh shower first though
always shower before no it stinks up the
sauna if you don't shower before well i
guess you wouldn't know before and after
i'll fight you naked says real friends
can scream at each other and have a beer
afterwards that's true or a 40 or have a
beer and then scream at each other
afterwards that's usually the order is
usually reversed
madrax says check out altered carbon on
netflix it's a lot of what you're
talking about people have implants with
their memories and they can move to
other bodies
altered carbon season one was amazing
season two was like huh
like the first one is it's a dystopian
world earth people have these things in
their necks and they can actually you
know trans like be they can have their
consciousness transported other planets
and other bodies and things like that
and it's about like corruption and
mafias and things like that there's a
really cool scene where
this dude the main character is
undergoing like virtual torture but he's
like this elite commando and can like
break free and then they're freaking out
it's awesome and the second one is like
ancient aliens and like dna and just i
don't know other planets it's kind of
weird but other carbon is an awesome
show yeah the fungus is where mushrooms
came from you guys oh i mean obviously
the greatest movie of all time is the
super super mario brothers movie yeah
yeah come on they'd eat the mushrooms no
no are you serious
beverly hills chihuahuas three viva la
fiesta
is that what it's called yes
that's not you guys are plebes you well
you can go in the sauna with sheamus and
then put up the projector and then watch
that never go into sauna i'm a big fan
of uh psycho cop 2 psycho cop returns is
that a film i got to put that up set a
real film
police academy 6. this is good jason
diaz says you have to get the youtuber
cgp cgp gray on he has a video on quote
the trouble with transporters
yeah cgp grey is awesome he has a video
from a long time ago called this video
will make you angry that breaks down the
culture work and it just tells you how
tim poole acts he's just like examining
tim poole he's like he's like just
pictures of me he's like i hate this guy
he's so dumb
that you're watching i'm like
why are you mad at me i don't even know
you
no but it's basically like he talks
about how online communities
pretend that they're debating against
someone but they're really debating
amongst themselves about how much they
hate another yeah and riling each other
up and you see this all the time when
you go on reddit or you if you look at
like uh there's a political compass
memes on reddit is one of the best
online communities ever and i'm not even
kidding because
they actually are different political
ideologies having conversations and one
of them that popped up today was
left and right
and it was a leftist saying capitalism
is bad and the right saying capitalism
is good and then it said they're using
two completely different definitions of
capitalism the left is talking about
corporatism which the right agrees with
is bad and the right is talking about
open commerce which the left agrees with
is good um so that is very interesting
so the right is like regular
working-class people should be able to
work without interference from corporate
crony garbage and that's what they call
capitalism and the left says
basically the same thing but they just
have decided different words so they
hate each other i guess well i think
it's also because the left would argue
that if you have a system of free
exchange inevitably people won't make
the right decisions and power power will
be consolidated which there is truth but
that's i think
not the libertarian left interesting
yeah you've got lib left people who are
like capitalism is evil and i'm like
you're talking about corrupt corporation
you're talking about corruption like a
system where people freely choose how
they want to live is not a bad thing no
one libertarian side left or right don't
disagree but they're just talking about
i hate corruption government corruption
corporate corruption corruption is bad
agreed all right then
no i think corruption's good actually
hold on let's talk about that
i think we must debate hold on i think
this is a conversation just to create
another
who's our other who do we hate exactly
me
christopher actually so christopher
fisher says he has a question but um i
want to actually ask a question based on
his question before reading it do you
think that cows have souls yeah i
believe all animal i believe every
living thing has a sword about there are
different kinds of souls yeah it has a
soul a cloned cow yeah same soul or a
difference well because we so here's the
thing clones occur so we we label it
differently and it is a different
process but um so for example with twins
right if it is an identical twin what
happens is the the zygote splits
right at that early phase i believe like
i mean well the biological consensus is
life begins at fertilization so i
shouldn't call it a belief it's a fact
and
as catholics who believe there's a body
soul composite we believe in soulmate
occurs at that moment and so
when you have a zygote split and twins
occur we don't believe that like one
twin has a soul and one does and we
believe both have a soul so i would say
if you clone the clone still has a soul
even though i believe cloning is morally
wrong i don't think that the clone
doesn't have a soul if it's being
animated it's being animated what if
what if earth is just like a soul
factory
where life creates souls and then like
when you're born the soul like grows and
develops and then when you die your soul
shuffles off into the this gigantic
cthulhu monster who just eats your soul
i yeah i hope not
yeah that would sound shaped like a
plasmoid right yeah be a plasma and so
like you die and then you're like i'm
going i'm traveling wow what's that
gigantic oh no
yeah the the earth has a magnetic field
that's like a torus of energy and then
the sun has one that the earth is within
this big field so then the galaxy has
one that the sun is within and in every
field you see one of these magnetic
lines goes straight up and away from the
galaxy and we don't really know where it
heads but uh assuming the universal core
so i would imagine uh
what are we talking about
[Laughter]
that the soul is i was about to ask you
that the soul the soul moves from body
to body that's what happens when we make
eye contact i got lost in jack's eyes
you're gorgeous there for a minute
jackie well then
uh charles balozian says i watched this
show nightly with my dog by my side she
popped her head up at the tv and visibly
disagreed with you jack and sheamus
she's also a machine who hunts rabbits i
i'm getting texts from my fiance
don't you talk bad about our dog don't
you dis on rosie
stop insulting rosie so i love you rosie
i love you
okay so she has a soul you think she has
a soul but it's different than a human
soul it's a little one i don't know i
was just asking questions just playing
devil's advocate i was taking on the ian
job for a second thanks you know i
wasn't gonna say playing dumb but yeah
yeah yeah jack of blade says i demand
the illinois boys play shadow run it's a
cyberpunk tt rpg game with magic and if
you go too hard into being a cyborg your
soul dies do you think the element also
catholic potential
fireballs
oh all right so if you had to pick it's
true if you had to pick become a cyborg
or a mage what would you pick neither
i would choose to go to private instead
you divine priests would you would you
would you their priests in dnd right and
d and d for sure i think i don't even
shadow run if they have divine magic or
not but like it's a caricature of a
priest you know
yeah
they they can they like
sure yeah they can like summon lightning
and like heal people with their hands i
mean it's like the full-on
mythic priest the healer a healer some
priests can become healers some can be
like priests of of of chaos and like
called on hammers and they can't heal
they can only harm that would be like
evil priests maybe a druid druids are
more nature magic they do use i think
divine magic as well because i don't
think an acolyte can use a damage spell
only healing spells there's some evil
priests out there some evil evil divine
beings out there see i'm totally larping
on my larping here i have no idea what
i'm thinking there's no idea what he's
talking about
either technologist or would you just be
like a brute fighter would you jack your
head into the wall and like and hack
computers why are these the options
of what i can do with my human yeah yeah
would be a dwarf
is the question
derek elwell says ian was right about
mushrooms they've proven spores survive
the vacuum of space mushrooms were here
before plants they break down rocks and
create the first soil layer on earth
check out paul stamets yes paul just
because spores
survive in space doesn't mean they came
from space
logic but it's evidence that they could
have that's where it means that it is a
i don't know if it's it's not evidence
but
it simply points to the fact that you
cannot disprove it by saying spores
can't survive in space
what he said sounded smart i would
actually echo paul the paul stamets he's
like the leading global mycologist he's
the mushroom guy phenomenal you think i
have respect for the feel of my college
you're gonna love paul yeah he's a sham
he's in a pod
mushrooms
um i i love this quote it's like um i
wanna give thanks to all the people who
came before me who ate mushrooms and
died so that i know which ones i can eat
for my salads and cheeseburgers totes
every time i go to the store i'm like i
love mushrooms just putting it on that
sandwich or whatever and
yeah someone someone had to die so that
we could know which ones were able to
eat all right we got we got one more
very important one
him posey says get off ian's back he's
he's most the reason i watch tim mostly
just covers the articles while ian is
the man for us 2015 woke alien boys yes
i mean truth be told ian is the reason
well ian is the backbone of society also
lydia are the reason why i keep coming
back well i mean illinois boys i mean
shameless jack this is a little weird
that you're not grateful for my
contribution to you coming back i got to
read these too
we'll start with rick ortiz says you're
an absolute muppet ian
yes but then alby damn says omfg i love
ian and the tangents he goes on at least
they're talking about me
could you imagine how all i care about
is helping people no such thing as bad
imagine how like dark and pessimistic
this show would be without ian i'd be
like the world's ending you're losing
and then ian's like but the vibrations
and the aliens are coming and then we're
like all laughing yeah we're bringing it
back more for genetic healing fields
yeah
yes exactly that
all right everybody we're gonna we're
gonna make this we're gonna make this
members-only illinois voice special
sorry i'm sorry it's gonna be a full
10-hour special podcast wait hold on
no sleeping so go to tim
i have a video to upload tomorrow i
can't just do 10 more hours
go to timcast.com become a member we'll
have that up hopefully around 11 or so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel you can follow me everywhere at
tim cast you can follow the show at tim
cast irl do you guys want to um
figure out who gets to shout out first
you go first you go first buddy ian you
want to go first yeah well lydia you
should go first because we skipped you
in the entrance we
[Music]
i'll elbow myself to the front of the
line jack brunch follow us on jack
brunch on twitter
jackbrunch.com we've got uh what's
coming up we're going to tampa on 10 10.
we've got nashville on 10 24 we've got
austin the beginning of december then
we're going out west we're doing denver
seattle la san francisco check it out
also follow me at jackman with live or
uh join the liminal order hmm
i'd like to apologize to lydia
i was rude that was like that was
exceptionally hard i'm sorry i was just
giving you a hard time you were just
being honest how rude she was to me
before the show it's the 40 year scotch
i just start being mean
she was throwing pretzels at james it's
true before the show tim can tell you
the way i'm tormented in this house
i show up she gives me a big hug you
show up and she's just saying she just
throws stuff at me sheamus was playing
galaga the other day and we were all
just laughing and high-fiving and making
fun of him i was crushed i beat tim's
high score into your foods doing this
well so so what happened was i'll tell
you the true story so i had like a the
high score like the default 20k and so
my galaga score was like 27 000. and
then sheamus came in and he couldn't
beat it and then we were all laughing
like look at me so dumb we can't even do
the captured fire
at lydia so all day today sheamus is
just playing the game non-stop for hours
that's true that's literally not true
it's true i was skating in the park and
i come upstairs and i see him he's just
like playing the game first of all i
finally at like 6 00 p.m he's like
he writes the score and i was like well
so i ended up getting 40 so so sheamus
beat me when i had 27 got like 31 and
then i got 47 five and now i've got 63.
so that's right and he was playing all
day i was not i was literally my my
workers can attest to the fact that i
was working with them through today and
you know what i played i think maybe i
played like three times today and still
beat your high score you're going to be
your high score wait are you good at
galaxy you get the double ship or do you
just bypass the double shift because
here's the thing about the double ship
don't use it i don't use the double ship
yeah here you have more service area to
get blown up exactly and i might i've
seen experts they just go single ship
the whole way also that one only gives
you one extra life i play in the arcade
there's two extra lives
two so i did this i did the sheamus that
counts as your promo lydia what's your
i deserve it for being rude to lydia
when she's literally been nothing but
kind of fine how about ian how about we
go in order oh yeah yeah let's do that
i'm ian crossland i'm from akron ohio
i'm 42.
and i love technology
thank you guys
it all checks out i can fact check all
of that so i've been sitting here in the
corner laughing at you guys like i
always do with the illinois boys they
crack me up you guys are more than
welcome to follow me at sour patch looks
on twitter
hey guys um i just wanna just wanna
apologize a third time here
for bringing me to my friend
um
my name is sheamus coughlin i have a
channel called freedom tunes we make
cartoons about politics and whatnot uh
we upload once a week sometimes twice a
week we uploaded i think a pretty funny
video yesterday i think one of the
funniest videos ever made as a matter of
fact if you guys want to check that out
um and we're going to be uploading one
tomorrow so yeah go check us out freedom
tunes go to patreon.com freedom tunes if
you want to help us make more i love all
of you sweetie everybody we'll see you
over at timcast.com for that special
illinois boys bonus segment thanks for
hanging out
you